this is jocko podcast number 343 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
if you know the enemy and you know
yourself you need not fear the result of
a hundred battles
if you know yourself but not the enemy
for every victory gained you will also
suffer defeat if you know neither the
enemy nor yourself you also come in
every battle
sun tzu
art of war covered that on podcast 23 by
the way which is over five years ago i
believe at this time
so
it's a real common quote though
we have to learn from ourselves we have
to learn our mistakes we have to learn
our strengths and weaknesses but we have
to learn
about our enemies and our enemy strength
and weaknesses what do we do right what
do we do wrong what do our enemies do
right what do our enemies do wrong
in order to know those things we have to
study our enemy we have to look at that
look at what they're doing
at least we should
we should be looking at our enemy
and in some
good times we
as a nation have been able to do that
well and we have a case here in 1942 the
us army intelligence
released a classified report about the
nazis
who they were
what they did right what they did wrong
what they had revealed in their own
manuals
so we got copies of some of the
nazi
manuals about
leading troops in combat
they have interviews or you know they
they
had quotes they have quotes from people
that they talked to german officers that
they talked to
and they put this report together it was
a classified report
uh eventually was declassified obviously
but
i got a copy of it to review
and you know at first you think oh well
what
you kind of think my my first thoughts
were oh this is going to be really
interesting to see these these
totally different viewpoints on
leadership right these are nazis these
are the most horrible people ever
okay so this is going to be they're
going to be totally different
well you're going to see that
they're actually not that different and
you can see
much of what they say
at a tactical level
is very similar to what any leader is
going to say and that sounds crazy right
because
and that's why you got to realize and i
think we when we when we covered
when we covered mao
and and i remember pointing this out mao
when he's talking when they're talking
about how to win a war they're talking
about well the main one the main case in
point is decentralized command because
he's talking about hey listen the the
troops out on the battlefield got to
make adjustments they got to make things
happen because they know what's best for
their unit at the time
and yet this same guy that says that
about how to win a war says oh but for
the government we're going to centralize
everything we're going to centralize
farming and we're going to tell you what
to plant and when to plant it and how
much to plant and you're all going to
die because it's not going to work
which is exactly what happened
so it's a similar thing here where
you can see clearly
that there's a huge disconnect between
the
the leadership on the battlefield
and then what's going on
with the with hitler the nazis
and the way that they were thinking the
way hitler was thinking
uh but some of the stuff is pretty
disturbing too
when you when you think about how this
whole nation was captivated and you know
this is something that the plasticity of
the human mind is something i've been
talking i've been talking a lot about it
on
on the academy
and
just how
people are so gullible and it's they can
if you're not careful
you can get manipulated very easily and
there's no greater example of that than
than the nazi party in nazi germany
just manipulation of the brain people
people crowd mob mentality which we
talked about on the underground mob
mentality going on and if that well he's
doing it she's doing it i guess we're
doing it and let's go
and then you think about you think about
how i mean look at society today look at
american society today
look a trend will go across american
society today
and you'll think whoa that's a trend we
can spot it
but people still do it right people are
in the trend and they're believing it
same thing happens
with the nazis
but here's the thing you think have you
ever known a
27 year old person that got caught up in
some trend and kind of went down in some
weird way went down it went down yeah
like went went off let's say went
changed directions pretty radically in
their life
27 year old human
yeah i mean yeah
what about younger and older what about
a 32 year old human yeah okay
now once somebody's 50 or 60 you never
know someone that's 50 or 60
no it can still happen but more rare
right yeah yeah i mean basically as you
get older you're a little harder to
manipulate it would seem it seems that
way yeah
but then when you start talking about 10
11 12 year olds
these are super
pliable brains
and so when i start talking about the
hitler youth you're going to be thinking
you keep that in mind
here's a 10 year old kid an 11 year old
kid that's getting indoctrinated that
doesn't know anything else yeah then you
can see where that's you can see where
that's going to end up yeah
so
the the thing about the third reich from
a military and leadership perspective
look there there was a lot of them 13
almost 14 million soldiers in the german
army
and they were efficient
they were efficient and they use
you're gonna see and i don't know i i
don't speak german obviously but the
translation they use that term
efficiency a lot almost like it's a
little bit scary
you know
you know where it's like hey is it it
wouldn't be more efficient if you only
had four three kids instead of four
you know what i'm saying like that kind
of that kind of scary thing
so we're gonna come across that word
efficiency
um
and and and the
st the german military the third reich
military was very effective and
efficient at the beginning of the war
and many people would i mean look at
what they did they rolled they
steamrolled through europe very easily
and a lot of people would say that they
continued to keep up a very efficient
methodology until that's when the nazi
generals
were running the show when you had guys
like rommel that was actually making
calls rommel who by the way eventually
got executed by
by hitler
but he was you know he was one of the
guys that was running the show and the
further along the war went the more
hitler started calling the shots
but they had some things that were that
were causing them to be so effective
early in the war you know they used
mission type orders they utilized
decentralized command
not so much a leadership perspective but
they had some really good weapons
um
bh liddell hart who we've covered on
this podcast he
he here's a quote from him from from his
studies
on a man-for-man basis german ground
soldiers consistently inflicted
casualties at about a 50 percent higher
rate than they incurred from the
opposing british and american troops
under all circumstances
this was true when they were attacking
and when they were defending when they
had a local new numerical superiority
and when as was usually the case they
were outnumbered when they had air
superiority and when they did not when
they won and when they lost
so they they were good at inflicting
casualties on
american and british troops they were
better than we were inflicted inflicting
casualties on them
that being said we had
you know obviously more numbers and more
aggressiveness over a extended period of
time but that's just one example of
the effectiveness of the german military
in world war ii again especially in the
beginning of the war
and
and there's there's more points like
that but i don't want to i don't want to
drill down onto that debate or or
go deeper into that
but there's no one that's gonna say
that the early german world war ii
military was
not an extremely effective military
force
and of course i mean we have to say that
it did fall apart eventually against an
incredibly adaptive and brave and smart
and capable allied force and and i would
say one of the best things about us
americans is we learned and we adapted
and i think that's
something that
maybe
you know part of our culture
is that we are able to do that and when
we allow ourselves to do that it's going
to be one of the most beneficial things
we can do is go oh you know what this
isn't working do something else
and i would say that the germans were
kind of the opposite the further the war
went the less they adapted the less they
changed their their strategies and their
tactics
and what causes you to not change your
strategies and tactics it's when your
ego gets too big what causes your ego to
get big when you're winning a lot so
just look what happened the germans are
winning a bunch they don't they think
that everything they're doing is right
we're losing we're like okay we got to
make adjustments the british are saying
we got to make adjustments so we start
making adjustments they don't
we win
look old
ultimate simplified terms right
and i'm not trying to make a historical
case i'm just trying to review
an assessment of some mindsets broadly
speaking
so
this report is is an interesting report
again it's written in 1942 and um
let's take a look at it what can we
learn from it that's the main thing what
can we learn from it so this is
september 17th 1942 the the report is
called german military training
and it comes from the military
intelligence service of the war
department
notice the information summarized here
is based on a variety of sources on
german manuals on technical articles in
german military reviews and above all on
the detailed reports of united states
observers who saw the german army at
close range in its work of preparing for
this war and during the first two years
of conflict
that's where it came from
introduction
the bull this bulletin proposes to
summarize information which will serve
three purposes one it will permit a
better appreciation of the basis of the
german military strength the strength of
the german army and its early success in
this war owe much to two factors
planning and training the nazi leaders
planned this war for years in advance of
their attack they prepared for it by a
system of military training which begins
with children of high school age the
training system was directed by the old
professional army it depended on effort
thoroughness and the appreci and the
application of old and tested principles
to the means of modern warfare
as an observer remarks the germans
believed that by hard work and hard
training they would quote save blood
later
and that's almost like a word for word
quote from patton
this training gave the german army a
time advantage over its rivals although
this advantage is being steadily reduced
it will contr number two it will
contribute to our knowledge of
characteristic german tactics those
principles of tactics and leadership
which are emphasized in training are
inevitably reflected in the actual con
conduct of operations while this
bulletin will make no detailed study of
german tactics it will bring out the
main doctrines which are applied in
battle as a result of training
number three it will suggest methods and
points of view which may be useful in
training u.s troops
so like what can we learn from this
that's what they're saying the there are
many basic similarities between u.s
training doctrines and those of the
german army though there are naturally
many differences in their use or
application we can learn from the
differences as well as the similarities
as far as possible concrete examples
have been given and in
in the appendixes there are detailed
illustrations
at some length of certain phases of the
german training methods
so
training in preparation for military
service this is where you start thinking
this is when you start thinking
this is going to be a problem if you're
watching this this is from 1934 if
you're watching this from the outside
you got to be thinking yourself this is
this is going to be an issue
here's what they got going on the nazi
government from the start was dedicated
to the purpose of war of conquest and
from 1934 on the party controlled and
directed every aspect of german life to
the same
so
right there if you're looking on the
outside you you gotta you gotta realize
we're gonna have an issue
this is like someone that's training
lifting doing jiu jitsu like this whole
person's life is for war
that's what the whole german
world was german military leaders have
followed clausewitz for years but only
under the nazi regime could his key
concept of total war be realized the
principle that every agency and every
individual of a nation must be used in
the effort of war
nothing is more revealing of nazi plans
and methods than the application of this
principle in a very broad program of
military training
the goal of this program was a large and
highly trained army but the shaping of
this army was not left to the two years
of actual military training for
conscripts
from the age of 14 boys were to receive
a preparation for military service which
would cover much of the basic training
ordinarily given recruits
so starting at age 14 you're starting to
get trained
at age 14
so you're getting indoctrinated and
you're getting trained at age 14. in
addition old men older than conscript
age
with or without previous military
service were to be given various types
of auxiliary background or refresher
training so it doesn't matter who you
are
if you're not in the military you're
getting military training
ages 14 to 60.
the nazi party through its various
branches was mainly responsible for
civilian training outside the army
proper this included due concern for
specialized training and skills needed
for mechanized warfare
a national socialist flying corps
sponsored instruction in the rudiments
of flying and in glider practice the
national socialist motor corps trained a
large reserve of youths in all type of
driving from mechanized service and thus
relieved army motor schools of many
hours of instruction
a german article in 1940 claimed that
125 000 men had been given experience in
military motorization
a motor boat corps cooperated with the
army and marines to prepare men for
water transport operations
so think about that
you've got
125 000 men that have been trained
to drive vehicles large vehicles
military type vehicles
i mean right now there's only 400 000
men or
men or women in the us army right now so
think about having 125 000 people that
you can draw that have this skill and
they haven't even been trained yet you
just got
them and by the way you've got people
that are know how to work on the
vehicles and by the way you got a whole
bunch of people that know how to fly
planes
kids
that know how to fly gliders
the activities of the party are
particularly concerned with the
indoctrination of all german citizens
for war the basic ideas in this
indoctrination are well known and are
reiterated in hitler's speeches the
theory of germany's natural rights the
concept of the master race the
exaltation of the state and leader the
glorification of war and military
virtues
the press
the schools press radio and movies are
controlled by the party and support its
efforts in every direction by propaganda
which has no has to fear no rival
the penal code prevents any free
discussion in the field of ideas every
german household belongs to a local unit
carry organized to carry out the party
educational program
so they they're down for the cause
there's no you you don't know anything
else yeah and if you think about
anything else you're gonna get found out
and it's gonna you're gonna get
straightened out
that's what's going on
a german lieutenant has summoned up this
work of indoctrination
in his parents home
in school in the hitler youth in the
subdivisions of the movement in the shop
and in the labor service the future army
recruit has been bred as a national
socialist he does not know anything else
but allegiance to the national socialist
state and the life work of being a
german
there you go
training of the german youth
the hitler youth
at the age of 10.
german boys are brought into the nazi
scheme as members of the young folk
young volk organization and receive
their first taste of official
indoctrination real shaping for the army
begins at 14 when they enter the hitler
youth
even before the war this organization
was mainly concerned with preparing boys
for the army both by instilling military
mental attitudes and by military
training a u.s observer gives the
following description of an exercise of
german boys carried out on a sunday
morning so this is a sunday morning we
got some german boys out there
doing some uh doing an exercise
two groups one mixed one of mixed hitler
youth and one of
one of young folk
30 strong and the other a similar group
of 22 cyclists on 11 bicycles marched
into greenwald forest under the command
of a hitler youth this boy appeared to
be 15 or 16 years of age he halted his
command dressed it with skill and
precision and announced his mission in a
clear and definite manner the enemy is
reported advancing from the south to
north through greenvauld forest at seven
o'clock he was reported to be entering
the et cetera et cetera my mission is to
determine at once and report to
headquarters the position and activity
of advanced units my sector is etcetera
etcetera
it will not be necessary to go into the
young commander's estimate of the
situation in his orders to his
subordinates they would have done credit
to a professional army officer this is a
15 year old kid
that boy still two or three years from
active service as a private in the army
was able to estimate a difficult
situation and organize and put an
execution a rather complex plan to carry
out his mission on a sector of sector
nearly a thousand meters wide
this demanded an extended series of
rapid fire orders it was evident that he
had control of his boys a continuous
stream of bicycle messengers carried his
reports from advanced units to the
leader's posts
he in turn sent frequent written
messages to some post to his rear
the observer was frankly amazed at this
performance and spent the entire morning
with this group to be sure there was a
certain amount of laughing and horseplay
among the boys this was not repressed
but any lack of attention to duty called
forth an immediate and severe rebuke
from the leaders it was evident that the
youngster in charge was on his own some
other means must have been provided for
checking up on how well that youthful
commander had accomplished his mission
two of his units one boy each failed to
follow instructions some were lost and
some had difficulty in reporting clearly
what they saw some failed in their
individual missions but the boy leader
did not fail in his he finally recalled
all of his units with skill marched them
to the rear and very ably praised and
criticized individual performance on the
whole it was a remarkable demonstration
of how german military leadership is
developed
14 or 15 year old leader and then a
bunch of 10 year old
little nazi soldiers out there on a
sunday
another observer saw hitler youth
organization
engaged in battalion maneuvers and
reports that their performance would be
credible
to regular troops
in 1939 the stormtrooper section of the
nazi party took charge of the hitler
youth
and after the start of war
boys 16 to 18 years of age were
compelled to take six months of regular
pre-military work the aim was to provide
the army with the largest possible
reserve of mentally physically and
militarily trained young men the
training includes infantry fundamentals
care and use of weapons and signaling
the hitler youth has been used in
in a variety of auxiliary services
during the war spotting aircraft
performing office work at airports
painting runways harvesting crops
tending children
in day nurseries collecting useful junk
and trash soliciting for the winter help
singing at the hospitals and putting on
entertainment for soldiers at the front
and obviously as the war went on and
they lost more uh
adult males the hitler youth started
fighting as well but this is where they
started off the following statistics
based on estimate by a u.s observer
suggests the scope of the variety of the
hitler youth activities
the national socialist flying corps
furnished the hitler youth flyers with
enough gliders planes and instructors to
teach
135 000 boys how to fly each year
the motorized units of the hitler youth
enrolled
295 000 boys each year the national
socialist party set up 1 300 repair
shops for the units and each year
provided them with 5 000 motorcycles
the hitler youth marines had an annual
enrollment of 78 000
the national socialist party supplied
the hitler youth with 10 000 revolvers a
year and a large number of rifles enough
rifles were furnished to enable 30 000
outstanding marksmen to participate in
rifle matches
the hitler youth had its own firearms
school
during an average 12 months the hitler
youth conducted
540 official outdoor camps which were
attended by 565 000 boys
that's every 12 months
this that's bigger than the us army by
the way
565 000. that's bigger than the u.s army
that's bigger than the united states
marine corps let me ask you this what's
your current
right now what's your current like
feeling about this does this sound like
real sinister or does it sound like kind
of squared away well it's both yeah
that's what that's kind of why it is
because the part of me is kind of like
well just because it's overshadowed by
the fact that it's the nazis
it's like oh my god this seems real
sinister but you get that part away like
what if it was like for something good
it's kind of like that's a squared away
group right there you got that much
preparation from that early on
that many capable people starting from
that early well that's kind of solid
like you could apply that concept
to some good things and that might help
us yeah
well unfortunately for you that little
that little part about them being nazis
is a real freaking problem it's a big
deal it's a real problem but there's a
whole bunch of things going on there
just just the fact that they their their
their foresight is so strong
that they're going hey look we're going
to be fighting a war in x number of
years we need people that can work on
vehicles we need people that can fly
planes we need to be people that can
drive vehicles we need people that can
fight we need people that can can shoot
well like they're just covering all the
bases
yeah and and obviously the part that's
very glaring
besides the fact that they're nazis is
um how they're forced like the use of
for where they have to do it yeah and if
you even think about other stuff that's
a violation yeah
and we'd have to i'd have to do some
more research on this but i can tell you
from what i know
the term forced
is not like a a great term to use
because everyone was so swept up in the
movement
that it was more like
that's like saying uh
during world war ii in america
you know americans were forced to start
a victory garden
you know what a victory garden is
victory gardens where you know you go
out in your yard and you plant tomatoes
and carrots for yourself so you didn't
have to so you could you didn't have to
uh get stuff from the store oh okay so
you could so everyone didn't need to
take supplies away from the soldiers
well you didn't get forced to do that
you did that because that's what we were
doing to help out yeah yeah okay so when
you see like the young hitler youth
they're not like
being dragged away to camp no they're
they're
fired up to go
yeah and that's what we're doing and
that's what they've been told and and
and they're also getting told like well
this is what we do and this is what
makes us better than everyone else yeah
yeah yeah you're right that is that is
they're still
sin it seems sinister oh it's 100
sinister but yeah it is different
because the ultimate purpose is we're
going to take over the world yeah yeah
the last part there it says in one year
six million german boys participated in
sports events organized by the hitler
youth office
next section is labor service at the age
of 18 german boys entered it
entered a compulsory labor service for a
six-month term the labor service work
gave them excellent conditioning and
hardening
furthermore it accustomed men to living
in groups under military discipline
and again you know what this is what's
interesting about the military
that stuff brings you together and makes
you feel good and makes you
a better person
and it makes you bond with your friends
you want to want to get people together
you want to want people to bond but make
them do hard stuff together that's
literally how you make people bond
shared suffering so we're going to go
out we're going to work really hard in
the fields and at the end of the day
we're gonna come back and we're gonna
have meals together
and we're gonna go out and do the next
thing
the same thing the next day
and and people that work hard are gonna
be rewarded
and people that slack off are gonna be
cast out so you see what i'm saying here
this is like a huge unifying thing it's
not that it's not forced labor like oh
god they're gonna put no yeah yeah oh
hey is your chance hey you're gonna get
to go to to get to go to the the the
labor service
oh you're old enough to do labor service
now it's going to be great
with the outbreak of the war most of the
male labor service units were
transferred to the armed forces to serve
as construction companies and the size
the units were increased from 200 to 400
in some cases 600. on december 20th 1939
a law ordered that normal label labor
service for men was to continue despite
the special war work of the construction
companies
the labor service youths perform
miscellaneous tasks in rear areas being
kept out of combat areas as much as
possible
and also says generally the girls branch
performs none of these duties except
pertaining to agriculture they work in
factories and do other types of work on
the home front so the females were going
into this too
but the males were cultivating farms in
occupied areas doing agricultural work
in germany wherever there are labor
shortages constructing and maintaining
important highways constructing
improving fortifications bridges and
airports salvaging equipment munitions
and material and battle areas policing
battlefields performing century duty in
occupied areas camouflaging and
sandbagging military establishments and
assisting in the transportation of food
ammunition and fuel during rapid
military advances so they're basically
just full combat support
and where does this end up here's the
conclusion when german youths at 19 were
inducted from military service most of
them had already had the equivalent of
basic military training works were in
excellent physical condition and had
been indoctrinated both with nazi
ideology and military attitudes as a
result their training period as
conscripts could move very rapidly
through preliminary stages in two or
three months the conscripts could take
part in maneuvers involving divisions or
armies because of the work done by the
hitler youth and the labor service the
two-year training in the army could
advance much more rapidly and
effectively
so that's a brilliant plan
hey when when people are finally ready
to serve at 19 we're already gonna have
them almost completely trained up
they're gonna be almost completely
trained up we have to waste i mean
marine corps boot camp is 13 weeks and
then you go to the school of infantry
the army boot camp is
i don't know eight weeks and then you go
to ait the the army infantry training so
so you're getting it's going to take
some time it's going to take four five
six months to get someone ready to fight
they're cutting two three four months
out of that program
which is a big deal
furthermore german boys had received
good opportunity to practice and develop
qualities of leadership and officer
material was already clearly marked out
by the time they reached military age so
they're looking for leaders
[Applause]
next section work of the essay
the stormtroopers the brown shirts which
is the nazi paramilitary wing
one of the most active branches of the
nazi party the sa
had particular responsibility in
connection with the hitler youth in
addition the sa performed important
functions in giving a certain amount of
military training to older civilians
both within and outside its own ranks
the essay as a military reserve when the
nazi party was rising to power the essay
and the elite guard the ss was in effect
a private army of hitler when he seized
controlled the state the sa was
gradually merged into the framework of
the military system and became more
closely connected with the regular army
by 1935 more than a hundred divisions
called brigade of sa troops had been
organized including men over 45 years
old the regiments were named after their
old pre-versaille units and carried on
their traditions only a few units were
technically part of the armed forces and
the main function of the essay was to
provide continuous and effective
military training for a large mass of
civilian populace outside the regular
two two year service conscripts in the
regular army by 1939 the sa had been
organized to provide specialist training
in such lines as cavalry signaling
engineers medical service and navy
one of its important jobs was given to
military training
of men over 21 who had not received any
training in the pre-hitler years when
germany's army had been restricted to a
small standing army
the sa
gave a coveted sports medal on a basis
which shows how very well everything in
their program was pointed toward
military service
the examinations for this medal include
aside from running and swimming tests
rifle shooting camouflage hand grenade
throwing
marching 25 kilometers with a 25 pound
pack and a 200 meter dash in gas mask
etc
by 1939 this sports medal had been
acquired by 800 000 men outside the sa
ranks
this is total war and we're all that's
what we're doing
it's crazy to think
as you watch world war ii unfold
that hitler was able to push as hard as
he did and get his get away with as much
as he did without somebody going hey bro
you're done you can't do this anymore
an important aspect of the essay
an important aspect of the essay control
of reservists was the fact that all
these men would remain completely under
the influence of the nazi party and
doctrine and controls
conclusion with the approach of war the
sa members were largely called into the
regular armed forces as individuals
rather by than by units enough of the
leaders remained however to continue to
work with the hitler youth and with
other older civilians not yet called out
according to one estimate one million
five hundred thousand men were receiving
essay training largely on sundays and
evenings in the spring of 1940. the work
done by the sa provided a great mass of
partially trained men in all age groups
who would be who could be quickly
organized and used in regular divisions
on the outbreak of war
a large part of the german military
training had been accomplished with men
who were technically in civilian status
as a result a german division during the
war could be sent to combat with a
minimum of training let's just
[Applause]
they're just focused on on this one
thing
and they knew it was coming
and it's strange to think that the rest
of the world
i mean the rest of the world knew it was
coming you can go back and look at those
old like political cartoons and you'll
see all the political cartoons are
showing hitler and and germany just
getting ready to go ham
this is a this is a very interesting
section here procurement and training of
officers
in preparing for the large army used in
his war of conquest hitler faced the
serious problem of developing an
adequate number of trained officers to
operate 300 or more divisions and the
various specialized corps and services
this problem was solved in large part
between 1933 and the beginning of the
war
one advantage at the start was that the
small standing army permitted by germany
by the versailles treaty had had been
excellently trained so after world war
one germany wasn't allowed to have a big
army they were allowed to have like this
little tiny army and so they focused on
that army really hard and got him very
well trained
also it preserved the best traditions of
the old german army and constituted a
valuable reservoir of officer material
for the rapid expansion of the new army
in addition there were available many
thousands of men who had served in the
first world war and who could be used
again many of these took part in the
essay training activities discussed
earlier finally the german general staff
maintained its high standards and
prestige and was ready to deal with this
problem of officer procurement
so
they knew out of the gate that
leadership was going to be an issue and
that they were going to have to field
good officers and how do you do that you
need to recruit the right officers then
you need to train them properly
officer training prior to the war the
program of training which produced most
of the regular army officers in this
period throws light on the character of
the army its relation to the pre-hitler
army and the high quality of standards
prescribed for officers the civilian
youth wishing to secure admission
applied to the particular regiment or
unit of his choice
so if you want to be an officer you got
to apply to a specific unit hey i want
to be an officer
he must be unmarried be an aryan and
have a certificate of graduation from a
gymnasium which is apparently the
equivalent to a second year
u.s college work
he was given interviews by an examining
board of officers and examinations which
tested his moral qualities and his
ability to stand up under strain
much importance was attached to a
psychological test
after passing these examinations the
candidate now a cadet
served for one year in the ranks of the
unit which received him so that's pretty
cool
so you apply they screen you they test
you they see how you respond to pressure
if they accept you you go in and you
become one of the troops you don't
become an officer you just become one of
the troops and you serve in the ranks
there he received the same training
given ordinary recruits and enjoyed no
favors
it was desired that the k that the
cadets should thereby learn to
understand the mental attitudes problems
and points of view of the common soldier
on the side and in addition to regular
training the cadets did special study on
the use of weapons
after this year so after a year of that
so you're going you're going to be a
normal
trooper
after after this year the cadets were
sent to a military school for nine
months and received basic training and
military theory identical for all
branches of the service so that's a
pretty good move you take everybody from
the army navy air force marines you put
them all through the same training so
they all have a baseline of knowledge
and understanding
there were four such schools admirably
equipped without regard to expense the
course included field exercises about 2
500 officers a year could be turned out
in these schools after these nine months
the cadets went to a weapon school
destined to bring the candidates back to
earth from their theoretical courses
here they received training appropriate
for their particular branch and an
opportunity to command and train units
attached to the school
finally the cadet performed two or three
months tour of duty back with his
regiment and then if elected by
unanimous vote of the officers in his
unit he was received for promotion for
promotion as a second lieutenant
this method which bears the hallmark of
the old prussian aristocratic tradition
was mod was modified gradually by
provisions which made it more possible
for reserve officers and specially
qualified ncos to obtain commissions
that is a thorough
screening process
to get
to be a an officer in the military
even i mean you come back from all that
training
and then they have to have a unanimous
vote that you're good to go
and only then do you become a second
lieutenant
he said that there's the hallmark of the
old prussian aristocracy that seems a
lot less aristocratic
than
then the american system the american
system you become an officer to go to
college
so if you're my if echo is my kid
and i'm like well you know i kind of
want you to be in charge i'm going to
send you to college and then you can go
be an officer
here you got to apply
then you gotta get screened then you
gotta serve as a grunt then you gotta
get screened again then you gotta go to
this school for nine months then you
gotta get come and get voted on to see
if you're gonna be an officer or not
yeah and
what do you think that's based on the
american way to do it like where you
have to go to college first like do you
know what the basis for that is uh so
it's it's an aristocratic thing
i want oh i'm a rich aristocrat i want
my son echo to be a leader i don't want
him being with the troops yeah i don't
want him to be with the enlisted swine
no so i'm going to send him to college
and then he becomes an officer yeah but
then why why is that the criteria though
you know like i wonder what
i mean maybe on the surface you can kind
of tell because like well if you go to
college that means you're obviously
smart therefore an officer as a leader
has to be smart or something kind of a
thing that's what it feels like anyway
that's probably conceptually
but
that's has nothing to do with anything
to be honest with you yeah the reality
you mean there has not been a reality
yeah but so okay there there are
brilliant
enlisted guys yeah that's what i think
grew up in wisconsin on a farm and they
did parents didn't have any money to
send them to college so he enlisted the
army yeah so what what now he might
eventually become an officer he might
put in first commission or whatever but
he's already
he's not going to be caught up to the
guy that was grew up in
with a rich family that was like listen
son you're going to college and you're
going to be an officer
yeah so how is that the criteria like
why did that come about the thousands
it's the aristocrat
that's why i'm laughing because they're
saying this is like the aristocratic
tradition i'm like
hey if you're whoever wrote this in 1942
the officers were aristocratic tradition
in america 100
yeah it's an aristocratic tradition oh
well you've been to college so then you
get to be in charge of all these people
that haven't been to college right
because you're higher class because
you're a higher class you're an
aristocrat they're not
yeah kind of when you think about it
especially that part about voting them
in oh yeah like that's kind of like and
making them a grunt now look if you go
to the naval academy or you go to west
point you spend like the summer on a
ship
as like a swabbie
right but
that's not the same as doing a year in a
line unit it's not the same dude
and and that you have to do that in
order to get recommended yeah because
there's a lot of officers if they
actually spent time as a grunt people
would be like oh this game this guy and
get one this guy ain't got what it takes
he might be able to graduate college
being able to graduate college has
almost no bearing on being fit to lead
troops in combat yeah that's kind of
what i figured
so in a way you know obviously i don't
know obviously but in a way this way
that they're talking about kind of seems
like
more accurate it seems like a better
system yeah yes it does
so they got to go through like kind of
more more uh applicable stuff yes to
achieving get yes get um you put
somebody with a line unit
where even if they're a machine gunner
their machine they spend six months as a
machine gun and they may then become a
fire team leader that person you'd be
able to go hey look this guy's a really
good fire team leader
yeah he should make it into this go to
the officer school
but if he's a dud
yeah as a fire team leader he's not
going to be a good squad leader he's not
going to be a good platoon leader yeah
which kind is and which seems like
that just because you go to college it
wouldn't necessarily screen any duds out
it's going to scream at zero duds or
close to zero yeah i mean and then at
the end as a final i'm assuming
screening scenario you're gonna get
voted on yeah yeah if if somehow you
maneuvered your way through after
what do you think you're going to go
through in those two or three months i'm
going to be testing you like if i'm one
of the other awesome you'll be like all
right let's see how you doing here run a
raid on this on this training mission
yeah let's see how you do bro
and wouldn't because like you know how
there's it's kind of like survivor
remember you know that show survivor
yeah on tv or whatever it's kind of like
that it's like the final
the final judgment where it's like you
can maneuver your way through stuff and
whatever but if they at the end of the
day don't want you to win or be on the
team or be a officer be whatever yeah if
your team does not want that that that
show was kind of messed up the way the i
think it was an unintended consequence
of the show was that
you know if who the people that got
would get crushed first would be the
people that had the the the most
potential
yeah you remember that yeah you know
yeah you're i think you're right
unintended because it seems like an
unintended consequence yeah but it did
kind of lead to the the natural
evolution of the game game like where
yeah there was more game to it yeah
because it's like when you first start
game yeah yeah and that's really what
we could say because because you might
be like hey look what they had
challenges right two teams and here's
the challenge
and your thought should be hey i'm gonna
help the team win this challenge because
i'm good at uh uh rope climbs right yeah
hey i'll we gotta do four rope climbs
i'll do three of them yeah and and then
you know someone do the last one because
i'll be tired okay cool let's get rid of
jocko he's too strong
yes you know what i'm saying so that's
actually what happened on that tv oh
yeah so it when i the weird thing is i i
actually don't watch that much but i've
watched i remember like one one season
of it i think the first season that came
on or maybe the second season
the first season had rudy bosch on it
who's like uh uh
epic
seal
and you know
one of like most respected awesome
old-school seals and he was and he was
pretty old when he did it he he
unfortunately passed away but just uh
so you know everyone kind of was
watching like see what the show was
about yeah actually one season one of
the girls from here from victor who's on
there really or yeah one of the uh cara
k okay i'm pretty sure those surprises
right now
i don't know i forget i didn't watch it
but i i watched like some of them you
know i don't know who won though but um
yeah we'll survive so why are you
talking about this again because
at the end they got the council so that
council scenario oh so you so if you
were a total backstabber backstab then
the council would vote you out that's
only one reason though that's only one
reason or like if you were hard to get
along with somewhere along the lines
yeah they would vote you off because of
that but somewhere along the lines they
would utilize those things too so
basically it gave rise to like this game
within the game just like you said where
you being strong at challenges
is an element it can be used for your
advantage or against you you know kind
of a thing and that goes for every
quality that each individual
demonstrates
so the thing about survivor
unfortunately it's like a winner take
all kind of the thing at the end where
they just get money one guy actually two
people but did anyone ever make deals to
say like hey if you and i win i'll give
you half
i don't know of any but if that were to
happen that wouldn't surprise me because
it's all within the game you know
because i think at the end too or
towards how much they win a million i
think one million dollars yeah and then
the second guy second place got
way less but a significant amount as
well
but it at the end of it too or towards
the end they would um
if you got voted off it's like at the
last four or five or however many people
if you get voted off
you get to go on to this council
that has a say in who's gonna win or
something like that so see how that
weird balance kind of is where it's like
you get voted off you better be
squared away you better be a good person
you better be whatever you know so it's
like the final you know thing where it's
like yeah you could be good at this this
and this but if you don't have at the
end of the day enough of what it takes
that we think everyone else in the group
within the group thinks right you ain't
gonna make it i don't care what how cool
you think you are yeah it's good to have
multiple assessments which is the
program that we're looking at right here
what the nazis did multiple assessments
in the actual environment where you need
to step up
and you're going to get
a decent result
more decent than said well you know fred
went to college so he should be in
charge of a platoon of soldiers
you know
he hey look there's some great officers
yeah
the interesting thing it was great
officers that went to
the academies there's great officers
that went to rotc there's great officers
that went to ocs
there's horrible officers that went to
the academies there's horrible officers
that went to ocs there's horrible
officers that did rotc
and it kind of surprised me when i first
worked with
military academy officers
i thought to myself hey these these guys
have been training for four years to be
leaders
like this guy is going to be awesome
that was not always the case yeah and i
realized that it was more about
that you could have some office awesome
officers that went to the academy and
you could have some terrible ones yeah
and you could have all you know it
didn't matter where they were from it
was who they were as people that was
what was much more important yeah deep
so when you went to cut because you went
after right yeah unless you're at first
so when you went to college do you think
that that college experience helped you
in your officer
position it helped me because i became a
better writer and reader
yeah like i was an english major
and i i remember reading
like directives
and rules of engagement and and not that
i knew i knew how to read them so that i
would understand them better and i got
that from having to read shakespeare bro
i hate to say it i know it sounds like
freaking stupid but when you read
shakespeare you you have to look up the
words you have to see what the context
is and i realize if when i before i went
to college i'd be like i don't really
know what that means but whatever yeah i
get the gist right and that getting the
gist doesn't cut it and then i realized
also writing a report or writing an
award or writing an evaluation same
thing i'm like he'll know what i mean no
i'm gonna make sure that my boss
understands what this means and you
think that college taught you that 100 i
mean dude i was one time i took five
english classes in one semester
that was ignorant bro that was one of
the dumbest things i've done
because i was just reading i was reading
and writing just like 10 12 hours a day
on the weekends i remember just reading
books it was ridiculous
and i took this one class
i was like oh this would be good like
nice little skater class little skate
class it was uh literature and film
cool
right so you got lured right into it
just like i did
it was like you spend all you know you
got to read the book
and then they get then you watch a movie
that they made from the book oh yeah but
watching the movie takes an hour but you
still spent 12 hours reading this
freaking god forsaken book oh yeah
especially so it wasn't it wasn't good i
understand nobody bothered good that's a
good tip right there by the way because
in theory you take all english you're
like i have to think about anatomy
or freaking
whatever else class i don't think about
that just think about english or
literature whatever we're doing no no no
check this out there's a book called tom
jones which is an outstanding book it's
an amazing book
it's probably 700 pages long with tiny
tiny tiny writing and paper thin little
sheets of paper
and it's really descriptive and it's and
it's about human nature and it tells
this story elaborate story with all
these different characters and so we
read this book
and then we watch the movie
in the movie there's no talking
no the whole movie is no talking they're
just acting they're just doing things
it just it was
it was real like
just picture any book picture any book
that you've ever read and there's no and
then you take that i mean just uh what's
it what's it like a take picture of tom
clancy
have you ever read what's a movie that
was a book that you like
a movie that was a book that i like uh
fight club okay so picture fight club
they take that book and they make a
movie there's no talking in it because
that's literally what they did i see
what they're doing though yeah i know
why they assigned that yeah no it was
cool it was cool it was very cool to
watch how they did it and just see the
interactions and you could
you could totally tell what was going on
just by the way they were looking at
each other the way they carried
themselves their body language all the
stuff
and and it was pretty
amazing to watch
but but guess what
still had to read that freaking book
still had to read that book and it
bothered me because
because i would always read everything
that i was told to read right yeah and i
think i might be the only person in
college took it as a personal ever done
that personal challenge yeah and i would
get like give us a quiz to check to make
sure you read you did the reading yeah
so they give you a little check and the
check is these are just questions but
you know if you read it you're going to
know
and i missed the first ques the the
first quiz about tom jones
i missed
i missed one question and i was so mad
and here's what made me mad is that it
said this is a it says basically this is
a book about
human nature
and the question was like what is the or
it said like the main theme of this book
is human nature
and so the question on the test was hey
what is the main theme in this book
and i put like the kind of the plot that
was starting to unfold but that was
wrong
and i was bummed out missed it that's
the one question i missed in that class
you're still mad about it i'm still mad
obviously i'm sitting here
what's that what's the word what's the
word they use now to describe a little
bit mad salty salty i'm a little bit
salty
uh so okay so
when you go to college i think i went to
the professor too i was like hey what
you marked this wrong
you contested it yeah you contested
actually that professor was really cool
uh she was cool and i had another class
when i was like hey uh you know doctor
you know you marked this wrong just want
to you know just show you that you
accidentally marked this wrong obviously
and she was like oh no it's a book of
the theme of human nature i was like
where are you getting that from and she
points to the sentence that literally
says that and i was like cool i won't
miss another question this semester
she said i know john because they all
called me jealous the only place in the
world anyone's that that group of people
called me john
was when i went to college because
it was on my what is that the the what's
the roll call called in the college
attendance sheet or whatever yeah so my
name was john and they'd be like john
yes it seems to make sense i was well
you can call me i didn't know that's not
my thing
it's not my fault yeah yeah i dig it i
did it fully so it so when you go to
college for let's say your situation
obviously these other scenarios but your
situation you're enlisted boom time to
go to the officer program i went to
office candidate school yeah school and
then do you go to college after that i
didn't i happen to go to college
afterwards my my program was very
strange okay so let's say whatever the
protocol is you go to college is there
are there like majors that you can and
cannot take to fulfill yes there are i
don't know what they are but they're
pretty i mean i don't think you could
take like
some totally
crazy
unapplicable thing yeah
but
you can i mean i took english yeah so i
mean but the english it's it feels like
english would be like if there was a uh
a list of majors that you could have
yeah and then the rest are unacceptable
for this program you think english
english would be on the list sure it
feels like it but there were
you or there were you definitely can't
pick something that's like i don't think
you could pick theater
yeah like because they'd say hey when
when actually you know you're going to
be standing up in front of talking in
front of people you might want to get
good at public speaking
right but i don't think you could take
theater i don't think although i had one
of my uh one of my assistant platoon
commanders
he was you know as a
as i was getting to know him like what
did you study in college you know what
he studied in college
he studied percussion
the drum yeah that's where he
he that's what his degree was in
percussion yeah i'm like bro it doesn't
seem like this is not going to help you
too much in the day
yeah or like
you know how people go hard with like
french poetry or something like that
where no i don't think you could get
more
useless than percussion
even french poetry might be more useful
than percussion
and i mean he was awesome a freaking
great guy but was he good at drumming
yeah hell yeah absolutely there you go
all right
um
so this seems like a very squared away
methodology for them just to to select
their officer now we get into the
training with the approach of the war
the programs for officer training were
enlarged and speeded up
in 1940 us observers estimated that
schools were turning out about 6 500
officers every four months
and that 30 000 new officers entered the
army between september 1939 and december
1940. man they are an explosive growth
curve
men applying for the for a commission in
the regular army continue to undergo
relatively long training course in
principle as thorough as that of peace
time and quite similar in plan
candidates for temporary war commissions
apparently receive a shorter period of
training sometimes
according to observers and reports for a
few months only all candidates for
officer grades must have had 15 months
of service and at least two months of
experience in the field as a leader of a
sectional platoon
although these standards ensure that
candidates have had considerable
background training nevertheless
expanding the german army to six times
its peacetime figures has produced
obvious problems
many reserve officers and ncos have been
commissioned from the ranks and from
veterans of the first world war
civilians have been appointed to
administrative posts older officers and
civilian specialists have been thus used
to free the line officer for his main
task leadership of troops in combat
attention has paid been paid to the
continuation training of officers in the
field so they had a way of taking hey
like echo trolls was a video guy
in the civilian world and they're like
oh you know what you're going to become
an officer but you're going to be in
charge of propaganda and you're going to
go make videos for the third reich and
meanwhile jocko who is a sergeant in the
army
and was a platoon leader or a platoon
sergeant in the army we're gonna make
him an infantry officer so they had a
way of kind of
putting people and using utilizing the
the knowledge that they had in a way
that's gonna help the whole
overall
effort
continuation training of officers this
has received a good deal of attention
since the start of the war owing to the
relatively short training received by
many officers the germans are
particularly concerned with the
progressive training of company officers
on whom depends the combat efficiency of
the fighting units
one of the essential duties of a
commanding officer in wartime is to
ensure the further military education of
his junior officers who must be made to
realize that to stand still is to
retrogress
interesting word retrogress yeah
yeah it's like digressed but this is
this is so important
when you're in charge of people you're
in charge of training them and you're in
charge of training your subordinate
leaders there's no training cadre
there's no big group up above you in the
chain of command you are in charge of it
and that's the same should be the same
in any company it should be the same in
your life you're in charge of it take
charge of it and then
the main thing that they're trying to
they must be made to realize is that to
stand still
is to retrogress that's what the nazis
were about blitzcraig right we're moving
we're gonna get after it yeah
the concept of continuation training is
broad it involves a review of
fundamentals with constant reference to
the manual of troop leadership
it stresses the need for versatility the
infantry officer must be must
familiarize himself with the cape the
capacities of other arms than his own
above all the officer must prepare
himself for emergency service in the
next higher grade or for replacing
comrades in other executive positions it
is the responsibility of senior officers
to assist their juniors and training for
the next higher grade
so they put such an emphasis on training
their subordinate leadership
german sources illustrate these
principles in the first place let us
outline the requirements for the
development of our officers the strength
of the german army has lain and still
lies in the platoon commander at the
front
this will remain so in the future and
the example of our lieutenants as he
stands and fights at the front cannot be
emulated by any nation on earth
according to a well-known saying of
bismarck
again that's some good propaganda you're
telling these young lieutenants you're
the one that's going to make a
difference it's like the marine corps
squad leader makes a difference
especially when you say it like that by
the way yeah
very good propaganda one would misjudge
lieutenant's mission entirely however if
one would have him conform exclusively
to the services of and requirements for
a platoon commander so it's not just a
platoon commander you gonna be actual
conditions require much more of the
lieutenant than mere service as such any
lieutenant may at any time have to
educate train and lead a company battery
or other similar unit and any lieutenant
may suddenly have to serve as a staff
officer or even as an adjutant or aid to
camp
the prog the progressive training of the
officer corps must be carried out with
this eventuality in mind so you're not
just trained to be a platoon leader
you're trained to be a company commander
a battery commander
a staff officer that's what you're
training to do everything
if the officer is ready to serve in
several different capacities at a
moment's notice he must be thoroughly
indoctrinated in the fundamentals of
tactics
this point emphasized in the german
source just quoted one difficulty
is that a great many young officers have
no knowledge of the fundamentals of
tactics many dangerous mistakes arrive
from this fact and during lessons there
is often vague discussion because of a
lack of understanding lack of
indoctrination is the most serious
defect it results in many unnecessary
commands
it results in many unnecessary commands
so if you don't know what you're doing
you're gonna make a bunch of unnecessary
commands
one must insist therefore that thorough
indoctrination of all officers regarding
tactical principles is absolutely
essential young officers must be
thoroughly familiar with the tactics of
all units up to and including the
battalion in this connection must much
work is needed older officers must work
to teach the younger ones
must work hard to learn
it is an open question as to which task
is most difficult but that is immaterial
the important thing is to attain clearly
defined objective
the ideal desire
here was summed up by a german officer
in a conversation with an observer we
apply simple methods to our leadership
you will find that our lower units are
so trained that many in them beside the
leader is capable of taking command
so there you go
keeping things simple
people there's multiple layers of
leadership ready to take over when
needed
and we're training and indoctrinating
them into the basic tactics so everyone
knows and understand them standards for
officers section five the german army
tradition set high standards for
officers both as to character and as to
professional ability great attention is
paid to this subject in professional
journals and books
particular concern is shown for officers
of company rank this is partly because
in a rapidly expanding army was
necessary to observe and integrate a
large number of new officers at lower
grades but it is also due to conviction
that efficiency and leadership standards
of these officers are of crucial
importance for the combat success of the
army
these officers actually lead the units
in the front line combat
with this principle in mind the german
general staff has followed a policy
which is described very clearly by a u.s
observer quote
in the german army leadership is
emphasized more than generalship
the general officer must of course
combine to an outstanding degree
proved qualifications for field
leadership mental resiliency and
executive capacity supported by unusual
physical stamina and ruggedness of
constitution
german general officers were selected on
this basis prior to mobilization
they won their positions in the pre-war
building training and equipping of the
modern army
all of them have had world war
experience as far as we know none of
them has been relieved from command
during operations the efficiency and
ability of these german generals seems
to be taken for granted they have
received practically no publicity during
the war
only one general general of infantry
eduard diedl
who commanded at narvik
has been brought before the public for
his accomplishments for his
accomplishments this was not for his
generalship
but for the qualities of leadership
displayed in situations normally
met with leaders
lower in the command
so
they're not even hyping up
generals
and you could see this is probably an
ego thing you know like hitler doesn't
want generals getting any glory he's
like hey give the glory to the soldiers
and but we got one general that kind of
acted like a badass okay we'll give him
some credit but everybody else you're
just doing your job give the glory to
the troops
you think well you think
you think hitler wanted competition
no
but okay so what's the strategy
according to your
theory obviously i think that's what
you're saying is that um
like okay so since the troops aren't
really in competition for glory it like
the top guy
so it give them the glory give them you
know kind of
the cred and the the
you know the props right
because generals essentially can be
in competition with him might be like he
looks at them as kind of a threat for
the glory in a way like we go to a
jujitsu tournament
and and you you're the you're a black
belt and you win
but i'm like hey you know what good job
you know fred in the white belt category
and uh on monday i get to give a big
speech and i give credit to all like the
junior troops because you're kind of a
threat i'm like i'm not giving this guy
any credit no see what i'm saying yeah
like yeah like some people like a
general is high enough rank that he
might kind of like
perceive my glory because he's too close
to my my lane
just didn't like that i understand
he says on the contrary leaders in the
lower command have received a great deal
of publicity since the outbreak of the
war so every young
you know german soldier that does
something awesome is getting this
full-blown credit and by the way what
was hitler during world war one he was a
corporal
he was running around uh he was a
communicator running he was a runner
so he's he's giving credit to those guys
another general principle underlying
german training of officers is the view
that good leaders can be developed for
lower commands by carefully training for
leadership
is not confined to a few individuals
gifted with superior qualities however
every effort is made to find the right
place for each individual according to
his special aptitudes and a good deal of
shifting is done in order accomplishes
so they take eyes and they go oh you
know what you're not this you don't want
echo you might be want to be over here
in the propaganda area because you're
not
good at making videos but we're not
going to put you up there running troops
you're thing
a german officer in conversation
accounted for his german military
success in a way which brings out main
standards of leadership prize in his
army
and this is what this german officer
says i would say that the success of our
leadership depends upon the selection of
officers of proved character and skill
and upon our system of learning each
required task and maneuver to perfection
by repeated process
one can only learn by doing
the proverb we vision is mocked
knowledge is power
is in truth not accurate knowledge
becomes power only when it is being
successfully applied in the gaining of
of an objective
so just because you know something
doesn't mean anything
and then they talk about character and
again it's very strange to be reading a
book about freaking nazis
and talk about their character and and
you know all that being said
and you're going to see some of this
here
this
this efficiency this this obedience this
loyalty
obviously all that plays into
the why this
why this this
system
was able to thrive so much because
you were being told since you were 10
years old hey you need to support you
need to support the fatherland you need
to support the reich
and you what you don't go against that
so if something doesn't look right
you go hey you know what it's the reich
we're pushing on yeah
you know as you like to say oh that's
what we're doing
so character
the germans fully realize the importance
of character as a basis for successful
combat leadership
their teaching on military leadership
reminds officers constantly of their
responsibility to lead by example and
self-discipline
a book called company commander this is
a german book a book called company
commander says
the company commander is a living
example to every man in his organization
to be an officer means to set an example
for the men the officer must be his
soldier's incarnation of soldiery his
model
if the german officer is inspired by
this mission the best and deepest
qualities of his soul will be awakened
his life's aim will be fulfilled if he
succeeds
through knowledge demeanor and
conviction in forcing his troops to
follow him
this is the manly purpose for which it
is worthwhile to stake life in order to
win life
in germany the road to rank of officer
is open to every capable soldier the
destination destination can be reached
only by efficiency in time of war and by
actions in face of the enemy
the real authority of an officer
is recreated daily by his entire
attitude
the ancient proverb applies earn it in
order to possess it
the more his men are convinced that the
authority of his rank is deserved
through moral worth
the stronger will be the influence of
the officer's personality
no one should accept that rank attained
by promotion will give to his position
authority sufficiently high enough for
him to relax his effort in the belief
that the objective has been reached real
authority is not dependent upon shoulder
straps stars and badges
it depends only on efficiency and worth
[Applause]
again you can't argue with that and this
is you know i i always say if you have
to pull rank in an argument then you're
wrong and that's what they're saying
here she's not it's not your badges it's
not your straps it's not your stars that
give you authority it's who you are
and no this is a great thing to remember
no one should expect that rank attained
by promotion will give his position the
authority sufficiently high enough for
him to relax his effort dude just
because you got promoted
doesn't mean anything you got to work
harder when you get promoted that's what
they tell you in the navy they're like
oh cool you got promoted cool now you
can work harder
you have more responsibility
discipline has always been recognized as
essential in german training and the
company officers are given the main
responsibility for developing discipline
by example
as well as in precept
the book just quoted says on the subject
discipline is the basic doctrine of the
army the objective of soldierly training
must be to make it unshake the
unshakable principle of every individual
if the officer
personifies physical and moral
discipline and thereby sets the example
for the conduct of his men he will
achieve his aim
even in difficult situations his
authority will be unquestioned if he has
convinced his men of his sincerity and
leadership
he need not most be the mo he need not
be the most clever
but he must be the most faultless man of
his unit
the german soldier has an instinctive
understanding particularly
the simple man of the moral qualities of
his superior
he cheerfully follows a leader whom he
respects whom he can admire
daily life on the battleground forces
the officer to be under the eyes of his
men day and night the necessities
this necessitates a large amount of
self-discipline both on and off duty
which includes not only cheerful and
conscientious fulfillment of all duties
but also modesty in requirements for
quarters and food soberness and drink
self-control and sexual matters
cleanliness and speech and a balanced
character
end quote
so what are they looking for
they're looking for that leader to be
beyond reproach now i i don't like
that they say hey the the leader doesn't
need to be the most clever but he needs
to be the most faultless and what that
sets you up for is trying to cover for
yourself it's trying to act like you you
know everything that's a problem
that's a problem
but the rest of it trying to set an
example
on and off duty
right not over drinking
discipline in everything that you do
it's weird they they talk about
self-control and sexual matters like why
does that come up that's weird right
come on bro yeah was that no fap right
yeah i mean that's just a weird thing
like it's it's strange that they throw
that in here what's going on what caused
that to come out you know what i'm
saying
well it's one of those discipline things
right where if you can uh what uh
refrain
from
i get it but like why is that in here
this is what this this is what a a nazi
book said
right self-control and sexual matters
because there are some deviant
freaks going on yeah and he's trying to
tighten it up you never know i guess
um but cleanliness and speech a balanced
character
goes on to say the german military bible
for company officers is the manual of
troop leadership this book gives their
basic tactical and combat doctrine and
there's plenty to say on the moral
aspects of leadership the following are
some quotations here's some quotations
from their books
war is the severest test of the
spiritual and physical strength in war
character outweighs intellect
many stand forth on the field of battle
who in peace would remain unnoticed
this is hype trade right here for
the troops the officer is a leader and a
teacher besides his knowledge of men and
his sense of justice he must be
distinguished by his superior knowledge
and experience his earnestness his
self-control and his courage
again
hype
the example and personal conduct of
officers and non-commissioned officers
are of decisive influence on the troops
the officer who in the face of the enemy
is cold-blooded decisive and courageous
inspires his troops onward the officer
must likewise
find the way into the hearts of his
subordinates and gain their trust
through an understanding of their
feelings and thoughts
and through never ceasing care of their
needs
mutual trust is the surest basis of
discipline and necessity and danger
so there you go there's a little
dichotomy coming at you
you've got to be the hardest dude but at
the same time you got to care about your
troops
through never ceasing care of their
needs
the nazi dichotomy of leadership
there
relations of company officers with
enlisted personnel
german directives stressed the
derivability of comradeship in units as
a moral basis for fighting efficiency
and again the company officers are
reminded of their responsibility the
company commanders is a book again the
company commander says
when the soldier learns by experience
that he is being taken care of
and that is the officer as his best
comrade who sees to this care then he is
ready
he will follow such a superior through
thick and thin and will cheerfully
perform the most difficult duties hey
hitler you might have wanted to read
that paragraph when you left your boys
at stalingrad to get surrounded and
freaking die
the officer must always set an example
by his own conduct and soldierly
qualities he must never think of himself
until his men have been cared for
i mean this is like leadership
one-on-one right never think of yourself
until your team is taken care of
only such an example can convince of the
moral right to demand services from
others only the model life
can confirm that right
the officer's own efficiency alone will
emphasize the necessity of his orders
again you get that weird use of the word
efficiency it's a scary word i don't
like it when nazis say efficiency it
makes me nervous
if the men copy the example set by the
officers
officers and men will be joined
comradely association and festivities
place the officer in a situation
basically different from that in times
of peace
he must never represent a contrast to
the privations and restrictions which
the men necessarily take upon themselves
and he must never forget that their need
for association and festivity is no less
great or justified than his than his own
so that's what that's saying right there
is that when you're an officer and your
team has to sleep in the field or they
have to go without food or they have to
go without water you need to do the same
thing
burdens and privations restrictions and
negations are shared mutually and
equally every company commander must be
a spartan
his must men must feel that privations
mean nothing to him that he rises above
such problems and that daily
difficulties cannot break his spirit
again
solid advice
continuing on the company officer is
advised to be severe when necessary but
without resorting to abuse to
disciplinary punishment as rare to use
disciplinary punishment as rarely as
possible
and always in a way that is clearly
justified
to take an interest in the personal
difficulties of his men to maintain a
cheerful atmosphere under all
circumstances to visit a and converse
with troops in quarters and to take the
greatest care in choice of supervision
of non-commissioned officers this does
not seem like nazi stuff that's exactly
what i was thinking i was like oh dang
these guys seem
i'm gonna say it not gonna sound correct
but they kind of seem like good guys
yeah well that's that's the scary thing
here it's saying like straight up like
don't um feel like physical discipline
or
right yeah uh disciplinary punishment as
rare use disciplinary punishment as
rarely as possible and
and uh always in a way that's clearly
justified
maintain a cheerful atmosphere
as a nazi i'm going to maintain a cheery
cheerful atmosphere it doesn't sound
yeah yeah it's it's interesting
well if you know at some point maybe
we'll take the the nazi theories
and apply them sort of through a
military lens and what it would look
like because what you end up with like a
tyrannical leader
and you must comply and everyone needs
to shut up and by the way we're going to
blame when something goes wrong we're
going to blame everybody else which is
kind of a key component to hitler's
attitude
which is the reason that germany is
having these problems isn't germany's
fault
it's the first world war and the
versailles treaty and the jews so it's
not our fault it's everyone else's fault
we're just blaming everyone else so if
we took that sort of higher headquarters
nazi philosophy and put it through a
mill put it on the military lens this
would look a lot different
taking it back to the book
german officers are expected to give
attention to the mental outlook of their
men and this includes giving them
frequent talks on the war
the soldier must know what the war is
that the war is his personal affair
and he must be instructed on its causes
meaning and progress
it is believed that the soldiers who are
informed as to why they are fighting and
of their part in the battle will show
improved discipline in combat
you've got to explain the why
newspapers radio and books are used to
assist toward this end an article in a
military review advises the company
commander to assemble his unit once a
week for discussion
the father of the company should speak
on all matters official and unofficial
current events politics
which influence the mental attitudes and
morale of the men troop leadership
reminds
officers that quote the leaders must
live with their troops participating in
their dangers their wants their joys
their sorrows only in this way can they
estimate the battle worth and the
requirement of the requirements of the
troops
man is not responsible for himself alone
but for his comrades
he who can do more who has greater
capacity of accomplishment must instruct
the inexperienced and weaker from such
conduct the feeling of real comradeship
develops which is just as important
between the leaders and the men as
between the men themselves troops welded
together only superficially and not
through long training and experience
more easily fail under severe strain and
under unexpected crisis
therefore before the outbreak of war the
development and maintenance of
steadfastness and discipline in the
troops as well as their training is of
decisive importance
so look that's from their book
the exact same stuff that you'll hear in
the u.s military
the precepts outlined above have been
actually carried out as uf
observers have reported during the past
few years one report states german
leadership is based on mutual respect
between officer and man we were again
impressed with the fact that cooperation
between officers and men works both ways
we're going to get into
principles of leadership section 6 the
training of german officers of all
grades for the present war has been so
conducted to emphasize certain basic
doctrines while these may seem rather
general in character they must be
understood in order to appreciate german
tactics according to observers german
combat tactics reflect the application
of these doctrines which are by no means
pious phrases of military theorists
the very concrete and practical manual
on troop leadership
is full of references to these
principles as later quotations will show
the german army
has been organized and trained to
operate as the task force principle
according to the definition of task
force is a unit of arms of all arms and
services under one commander for the
accomplishment of a single specified
mission this principle operates at all
levels of command when a mission is
assigned to a commander he is given the
means judged necessary to accomplishment
to accomplish it this these means are
turned over to him for combined training
by which his men are molded into a
combat team the members of this team
must know their mission and work
together for its accomplishment
individual units are called upon to
merge into the structure of the command
t of the combat team the training phase
permits commanders and staff to become
thoroughly acquainted with all their
officers in this way they
learn one another's shortcomings and
strong points so that many later
misunderstandings are prevented in the
stress of combat personal combinations
thus built up often becomes so strong
that they are maintained through
successive campaigns
every effort is made to discourage
rivalry between components of a team for
example through march song though march
songs are highly regarded and developed
there are no songs about the superiority
of infantry to engineers or artillery
etc
there are no inter-company or
inter-battery athletics to develop
useless competitive emotions commanders
of subordinate units are so imbued with
the feeling of cooperation that they go
out of their way to assist one another
they cover and move for each other
considerable attention is given to the
acquainting of officers of one branch
with the weapons and tactics of another
even the manual of a specialized branch
shows this effort anti-aircraft gunners
manual has a section on what these
gunners must know about their employment
as part of ground forces teams
including a discussion of divisional
tactics
the greatest factor in successful
deployment of armed troops is speed in
obtaining the initial coordination of
arms and in the execution of a
coordinated missions by various arms so
they are
absolutely pushing
for everyone to work together
that's what they're pushing for
we have to cover and move for each other
their next principle is aggressiveness
and a niche initiative
some people say default aggressive i've
heard
the prime characteristic of german
tactical doctrine
is maintenance of the initiative and
avoidance of stabilization the germans
believe absolutely that if a trained
commander prepares and executes
aggressive moves even with even average
ability and reasonable speed the enemy
will be kept too busy meeting them to
carry out a successful offensive
measures
the german officer
phrased the concept in a way that can be
understood by troops our men are taught
that their own safety depends upon their
getting to the enemy's rear and not
staying in front of him
this is fundamental of our training
these guys are looking to flank all day
long
aggressive tactics require the use of
initiative by combat leaders down to the
platoon commanders and non-commissioned
officers development of this capacity
for taking the initiative is stressed at
all points in military training whether
theoretical or practical no illusion
surviving the first world war is more
dangerous than the notion that german
leaders
especially of small units are bound by
rigid and mechanical regulations and can
move only in accordance with detailed
pre-arranged plans
so again that's what they started this
war off this 1942 by the end hitler was
dictating
they lost this
in actual fact german leaders of small
units have shown great skill in this war
adapting their tactics and flexibility
to meet new situations they have been
trained to do this
the handbook on the german squad in
combat illustrates the doc the this
doctrine
quote in the execution of battle
missions one should be most careful to
avoid the idea that only one solution
can be right can be the right one
only success in an actual case could
prove that a given solution was the
right one
a model solution must not be drilled
into the soldiers
they and particularly the squad leader
should be trained to be flexible and
should learn to be equal on any occasion
so this is kind of the antithesis of
what you think of a nazi right
just
calling out for flexibility and for free
thought
i mean free thought is the antithesis of
nazi attitude nazi attitudes we're all
going to think the same thing that's why
we're going to start indoctrinating when
you're 10 years old
no we want you to have free thought
and ultimately this kind of thing this
is one of the things that leads america
to have that open mind on the
battlefield to see what we can adjust to
figure out what we need to change and
start winning
german regulations place due value on
getting as much information as possible
about the enemy as a prerequisite for
action but regulations also prevent this
from becoming a requirement that crypt
cripples action
this is a dichotomy of leadership hey
look you've got to get good information
but don't let it you and wait
for it
quote obscurity of the situation is the
rule seldom will one have exact
information of the enemy clarification
of hostile situation is is self-evident
is a self-evident demand however to
weight intense situations for
information is seldom a token of strong
leadership but often one of weakness you
so you got to take action
you got to be aggressive that's got to
be your default mode
so the officer is taught to attack in
order to clear up the situation that's a
great quote
you want to know what's going on attack
figured out
and gain a basis for an estimate of
further action battle itself proves the
most reliable means of estimating the
enemy oh that's a good one
i don't recommend that in a bar fight
let's see how tough this guy is all
right
omission and delay are regarded as
greater crimes than the choice of the
wrong method of action
in training exercises the choice of a
tactical method is subject to full
criticism by reviewing officers but no
man is reprimanded because he tried to
do something and failed they want you to
do something
even that's a big one i mean kind of
it wouldn't seem that way but it seems
like that's a very surprising one right
there they want you to take action
that's that's the crazy thing about this
this is what we don't think the specific
fact that like you'll be
you'll be less reprimanded if you do the
wrong thing
yeah like you think oh you know okay so
you know like the expression right don't
be a nazi about it like grammar or not
yeah or you know soup nazi or you know
like that just as a whatever that kind
of expression it kind of says the
opposite of that where it's like you
better do it correctly or
almost feels like they're saying do it
correctly or don't do it all almost kind
of thing that's what it feels like
nonetheless it does feel like
do not make a mistake yeah or die kind
of a thing kind of a feeling that's kind
of funny like if you were to like the
grammar nazi one yeah
think about if you were legitimately
just paranoid about making a mistake and
having the grammar nazi come at you
and so what are you gonna do you're not
gonna write it yeah so you do what yeah
you're just gonna sit there yeah you're
not gonna put the word out so you gotta
be like hey
grammar nazi no yeah you can say hey you
might want to get justin here but good
try
that's what they're saying that's that's
being their grammar nuts
all right
here's some quotations from the troop
leadership manual
the teaching of the conduct of war
cannot be concentrated ex exhaustively
in regulations the principles so
enunciated must be employed dependent
upon their situation it's the same thing
dude it's not about regulations you got
to figure it out
the emptiness of the battlefield depend
demands independent thinking and acting
of fighters who considering each
situation are dominated by determination
to act boldly and decisively and to
arrive at success we just want you to go
figure it out we don't care how you do
it
the first demand in war is decisive
action
everyone the highest commander the most
junior soldier must be aware that
omissions and neglect incriminate him
more severely than mistaken choice of
means great success
presumed boldness and daring preceded by
good judgment they're just telling us
these troops over and over again make
something happen we never have at our
disposal all the desired forces for the
decisive action he who will be secure
everywhere
or who fixes forces in secondary tasks
acts contrary to the fundamental
oh i just need a few more troops to go
no go
hold on we're going to hold we got in
set security no go
hold on i need to figure out what the
enemy's doing no go
the weaker the force through speed
mobility great march accomplishment
surprise and deception the utilization
of darkness and terrain to the fullest
can be stronger at the decisive area
time and space must be correctly
estimated favorably situations favorable
situations quickly recognized and
decisively exploited every advantage
over the enemy increases our own freedom
of action
the attack is launched in order to
defeat the enemy the attacker has the
initiative superiority of leadership and
of troops shows to the best advantage in
the attack success does not always come
to the superiority of numbers
a german officer commenting on the
clearly
commenting early on the early campaigns
of the war recognized the capacity of
very young officers to meet these
standards of leadership so this is
pretty impressive before the campaign in
the west we underestimated the wonderful
leadership of our 22 year old company
commanders they acted without hesitation
where older men would have paused for
long consideration and heavy artillery
reinforcements time and time again we
found these young commanders calling for
a few 88 millimeter anti-aircraft guns a
handful of anti-tank guns and a platoon
pi platoon of pioneers to assist them in
taking a famous fortress and then
actually capturing it with no delay and
relatively few losses the enthusiastic
leadership of youth was one of the great
features of our advance west
so they did they actually this is like
one of those things where you program
the robot
and then it like does even better than
you thought it was gonna do they told
these guys advance you know fight go
be aggressive and that's what they did
and it worked and they were surprised by
it
[Applause]
next section is orders and
communications aggressiveness cannot
serve as the sole principle of tactics
without leading to disaster so there's
the dichotomy we want you to be
aggressive but if you're just being
aggressive it can be a disaster
german training supplements that
principle with careful attention to all
measures which provide that action taken
shall be considered and intelligent
these measures include orders
clear orders and an efficient system of
communications
simple clear and concise orders that's
what this goes into
uh orders should be clear and direct
should confine themselves to the main
lines of a mission
assigned to the lower command giving the
lower command latitude of choice of the
means to execute the mission so here's
what you got to do we don't care how you
do it
the germans believe that one of the
signs of deterioration in their armies
toward the end of the first world war
was the growing verbosity and ambiguity
of orders
they proposed to avoid these mistakes by
constantly drilling conciseness and
clarity isn't it interesting as i'm
talking to you more
it's becoming more ambiguous
that's what they're saying yeah
we started falling apart at the end of
world war one why
the more we talked the less people
understood what was happening
that's a that's a freaking very
interesting very interesting dichotomy
this is an interesting statement here
um
when we start talking about the way
these guys are sort of
living their lives
no german officer begins the day without
a mission
if the mission has not been received
received from higher authority he gives
himself a mission for the day
and one which is definitely not a mere
compliance with a printed schedule the
printed schedule is nothing but a time
allotment or control
he approaches this is the german officer
approaches each day's task as he would a
battle
in order that eventually he will
approach battle
as he would a day's task
just kind of living the life
yeah
uh
the manual of troop leadership says on
this subject of orders the order puts
the decision into effect clear orders
are essential for the frictionless
cooperation of all commanders for the
higher commander the written order
provides the foundation for leadership
it is communicated to the lower units
printed in carbon copy type written or
written by hand or by technical
communication means frequently as
dictated dictated over the telephone
in every instance the most sure and
suitable method of transmission is to be
chosen
the more pressing the situation
the shorter the order this is a mistake
everybody makes
what's what's challenging about that
is
in order for me to give you an order in
a pressing situation i have to be able
to look at the situation simplify it
and then distill it the the order down
into something that's like hey we need
to move north now
and there's a lot of other things going
on what we need to do is we need to move
north now and get this terrain feature
solidified boom that's it
go
that's one of the most challenging
things that leaders one of the most
challenging
things for leaders to do is to look at
complex situation and simplify them and
then verbalize
what needs to happen
that's something you can practice that's
something you should think about all the
time
that's something when you when you are
going to talk to your team
you should write down what you're going
to say and say it in as few words as
possible
that's one thing i kind of liked about
twitter back back in the day when i was
on twitter a lot
seriously it was fun you had to like you
had to like you had 140 characters and
then they made it easy gave you 280
characters yeah but back in the day to
140 characters you gotta
that's what you're gonna do
good practice became ambiguous after a
while yeah it did you know there's uh
that all it always reminds me of the
i think it's life maybe yeah life tells
the story of uh btf tony or leifel go
through his
his orders or whatever he's telling
everybody and then btf tony will be like
hey i'm gonna remember three of those
things which of them do you want them to
be yeah
classic btf tony
i mean
that would be so fun to say in a real
situation
i don't know how many people i could
pull that off with without them getting
kind of mad at me but
if you pull it off that'd be sweet yeah
well you can't get mad at btf tony for a
bunch of reasons number one he's awesome
number two because he's right you know
he's telling you the truth and you gotta
be happy
um
with important orders it is often
advisable to use two or more means of
transmission well that makes sense
it is easy to underestimate the time
required to get an order through oh
that's an important one i told those
guys yesterday oh they didn't get the
word yet
big shocker too many orders especially
in battle during which communication
means may miscarry produce the danger of
an impairing independence of action of
lower commanders so if i'm giving you
orders all the time eventually you're
just waiting for orders that's just i'm
centralizing command and i'm
micromanaging and it's going to be a
problem
an order shall contain all that is
necessary for the lower commander to
know in order for him to execute
independently his task it should contain
no more
and then they got a they got a chunk in
here about communications but
they're starting to talk about like
their technical communication so
no factor here
as contact is gained with the enemy it
is better that the division commander be
where he can observe
therefore he belongs early on the field
of battle
and in the decisive area his location
must be easily found easily reached
in attack the division command post
should be located as far forward as
possible
standby for dichotomy yet
so selected that the communication net
to the side and rear is effectively
shielded from hostile fire
to be desired are observation of the
battlefield either from the command post
or nearby observation post and the
possibility of establishing an airplane
landing field nearby so there's a
dichotomy
the nazi dichotomy i've said that twice
now i'm a little scared
[Music]
i don't want to make that a thing
knowledge of terrain
the usual attention is paid in german
training to correct use of maps as a
basis for utilizing terrain and maneuver
but the german doctrine
is that maps should be so thoroughly
studied that they can be largely
dispensed with during maneuvers
an observer who commented on the small
use of maps during tank exercises was
told that the officer who must
constantly refer to a map for
orientation purposes considered poorly
trained the map once studied should be
carried in the mind rather than in the
hand
that's
when you get in the military that's sort
of like
from a leadership perspective
understanding terrain is like blue belt
level like
and you know the difference between
someone that doesn't train in a blue
belt
is massive yeah
that's when you start to look at terrain
and understand terrain that's like when
you get your blue belt you're like okay
i understand i understand how i can
utilize the terrain that we're facing
to our advantage yeah and what you're
saying just the
the method to do it like the skill of it
versus no scale and even when you train
when we train as seals like when we
first go out and do immediate action
drills so we practice getting in gun
fights and breaking contact with the
enemy or assaulting the enemy the first
thing we do is we do it on a big flat
open field
it's desert but it's a big flat piece of
sand there's no terrain it's just flat
and you're just going through the
mechanics
and then as you get better you start
incorporating little pieces of terrain
and then eventually you're using like
wild terrain features
next section is called surprise during
the training phase the importance of the
principle of surprise in combat is
constantly featured according to german
doctrine surprise depends on the use of
secrecy deception and speed secrecy
depends on maintaining the strictest
discipline among troops according to
german military authorities the use of
deception to achieve surprise is
comparatively unexploited
speed of execution of any maneuver is an
essential is essential
for achieving
surprise
this principle is extended to artillery
practice an observer notes that as much
importance is now put on the speed of
opening fire as on accuracy and as the
attainment of heavy volume of fire
so i'm going to surprise some people
again this is a
speed surprise and violence of action
that's what you learned day two at the
seal team
section 7 training methods
subsection 20 physical conditioning and
marching
the importance of physical condition is
fully recognized in german training
doctrine
one of the services of the hitler youth
with its emphasis on sports and the
labor service is to furnish the army
with recruits who are fully conditioned
and toughened
the training period is thereby shortened
and made more
effective a us observer saw an infantry
battalion on maneuvers in january 1940.
with the temperature at 20 degrees the
troops lay patiently in four inches of
snow weighting their orders for over an
hour many men had no gloves
this difficult period seemed to have no
effect on their performance later
the hardening
[Laughter]
other observers of a german division in
field exercises before the outbreak of
war reported that fitness and endurance
were made a fetish by both officers and
men
the training purposes officers sorry for
training purposes officers often went 24
hours without food
troops carried heavy loads of mortars
machine guns and other equipment as far
as 1200 yards in fast rushes of 50 yards
just before the exercises one engineer
battalion had marched 85 miles through
the mountains in three days
good physical condition has been a basis
for the notable
march achievement of the german infantry
despite all the mechanization of modern
armies german doctrine foresaw the
possibility that motorized personnel
might lose their equipment and have to
move rapidly on foot in some cases
german troops under the prolonged strain
of combat operations have covered 30 to
40 miles a day for several days and
german sources claim a march of 44 miles
in 24 hours during the polish campaign
reserve formations of older men or heart
are held to nearly the same high
standards despite these achievements
demand is made for even grading greater
attention to marching
an article in a german military review
from 1940 states peacetime marching
practice though good
was not strenuous enough to prepare men
for wartime marching conditions in
peacetime marching too much
consideration is given to the comfort
and convenience of the troops
despicable tone added by me
yeah so you had these american observers
over there in 1940. actually you know my
grandfather was in the army and he was
over in nazi germany in 1939
and he was he was talking to nazi i have
i have his passport
and he actually he was an engineer
and he
ended up befriending
one of the nazi german
or nazi army engineers that worked on
weapon systems and he he became friends
with him and got a bunch of blueprints
of their weapon systems and stole them
and brought them back to america and
turned them over
he did a little espionage
but i have uh
i had his passport i don't know where it
is right now i think my my dad might
have it but his passport has like all
the the nazi swastika stamps in it and
stuff and when he was over there and you
know my grandfather spoke uh dutch
and so he met someone that they could he
could communicate with huh
like
oh he spoke to when did you because
obviously he was american
do you know when your family moved
yeah that side of the family came here
on the boat
in like
1900 or something like that um
it's nuts yeah it's crazy thinking about
those times like those were actual real
times you know
like before you were born you know it
feels like in your brain it's almost
like oh that's just it's almost like a
movie you know like before you were born
it's more like just a movie and all this
stuff but it was like an actual time
where people were actually living
actually going through their day-to-day
life yeah and you actually were
and you were like
you did not exist
no it's a hard one to contemplate
sometimes
i
i will i regret to inform you that the
world has been here before you were here
echocells
the world was not created the moment i
was born
all right all right cool
just saying
uh
emphasis on field exercises even the
training at the german general staff
avoids abstract theory in tactics and
strategy the student is thoroughly
grounded in fundamental principles of
tactics but he is taught to apply the
concrete by case study method in which a
specific situation must be stated and
solved tactical training at the school
is given almost entirely by means of
free maneuvers on the map and on the
ground no fixed divisional organization
is used in this training and the
combination of arms in the division is
continually varied the exercises are so
conducted that the officer student as
commander and his staff oppose either
the instructor or another student group
the student is given very little
information of the enemy positions and
is required to make immediate decisions
put into verbal orders movement is
controlled by factors of time space
terrain firepower and mobility and by no
other control features coordination of
effort is assured by snap action during
movement rather than by attempting
elaborate plans in advance field work is
done is field work is given central
emphasis in the program
of training for troops small units carry
out tactical problems day in day out
tactical exercises fill in half the time
of training this is just squared away
and you can have a you can do you can do
such awesome role and we've we're doing
a bunch of stuff at ashland front we got
the ftx going obviously where this is
what you're doing
you're gonna get you're gonna get like a
little bit of information you've got a
timeline that you got to meet you got
enemy moving you got friendly forces got
all this stuff going on and that's why
we do it so you can learn how to lead
we're doing something now we call the
the leadership lab where it's not a
combat scenario it's a business it's
business scenarios
so you're going in and you've got a
staff that you've got to work with and
you've got things that are happening at
your company who plays the staff other
people in the company are role players
role players role players play the staff
it's it's pretty awesome like oh hey
we've got hey hey listen boss or listen
uh
whatever
plant plant manager hey plant manager
you got a complaint one of your one of
your employees is flying off the handle
right now who says that
they're getting treated unfairly they're
coming to your office right now they'll
be here in three minutes
oh by the way as soon as that's over you
you there's a there's a reporter here
you've got to do a small press
conference there's a group of reporters
here they want to know about this
product that you made that's made a
bunch of kids sick in the local
neighborhood so you can get ready for
that press conference and then you go to
the press conference guess where you
guess what happens you could ask them a
bunch of questions buy role players
do you are you saying that your profit
is more important than the safety of the
children you know like all that kind of
stuff
so good yeah that makes sense yeah
echelon front.com leadership lab check
it out you want to put your key
executives through some awesome training
where they learn these these types of
leadership skills that's it
fast forward a little bit the concept of
wartime training stated
was stated in a german training
directive in 1941.
in spite of greater difficulties than in
time of peace training must be conducted
as thoroughly and methodically as
possible it is only by inspiring a
desire for intellectual cooperation and
by constantly keeping it alive among the
lower ranks that the correct tactical
conceptions can be successfully
inculcated in the ranks down to the most
humble non-commissioned officer
realism
the realism of training no element of
training doctrine is given more stress
than the demand for a maximum effect of
realism klaus wits the guide of so much
modern military theory stated the
principle vary exactly at a period when
the methods and techniques of warfare
put less strain than they do now on the
troops entering battle for the first
time that's an interesting statement
like hey back in the day is nothing
compared to you're going into combat in
and there's machine guns and you know mr
schmitz overhead strafing your area and
people are just getting blown up like
this is a totally different ballgame
yeah but this is a good way of putting
it from crosswinds no general can supply
his army with war experience
and the substitute of peacetime drills
is a weak one when compared with the
actual experience in war
it is much more important that peacetime
drills be so arranged that a part of the
causes for friction occur and that the
judgment the wisdom the prudence and the
decision of the individual leaders are
tested then is believed by those who do
not know from this experience
so you got to go if you invent a war you
got to go even harder
than you think
it is of utmost importance that the
soldier of high or low grade no matter
what position he may occupy should
experience those difficulties which
perplex and surprise him in actual war
if they have happened to him but once
before he's already somewhat familiar
with them
this even applies to physical strains
they must be practiced not so much that
nature but that the brain
becomes accustomed
this is
so absolutely critical and you know i
was so lucky to have been where i was
in and be able to run training in the
seal teams
because we just were able to execute on
this we were just absolutely able to
execute on this 100
and give super hard training stressful
training
decisions that needed to be made under
time under stress under pressure with
mayhem going on communication breaking
down like we were able to do this over
and over again
if you're a platoon commander you're
going to do this 12 times
in in 12 nights or in three nights or
four nights you're gonna be put in these
stressful situations you'd start to get
used to it
and your troops get used to it
this is why
law enforcement training needs to step
it up yeah
it need to step it up
about a thousand percent
so that people get used to these
scenarios from training
the germans have gone to great trouble
and expense to carry out this principle
in training for one thing troops and
training exercises are provided with
large amounts of practice ammunition of
all sorts including grenades usually
with reduced charges but nevertheless
requiring careful handling and involving
some risk machine gun fire ball
ammunition over the heads of attacking
troops with very small safety margin and
trench mortars support the infantry
within 50 yards of
its objective
a german officer of engineers told an
observer that we have considerable
losses in wartime training but this is
unavoidable in familiarizing the men and
handling of explosives and becoming an
expert the men know that losses in
training would mean fewer losses in
battle
in field exercise the enemy is always
represented by actual soldiers who
advance and retreat delay flyer fire
blanks and otherwise conduct themselves
that the enemy should barbed wire shell
holes trenches artillery emplacements
and all the other features of actual
combat are introduced as far as possible
in every exercise
remember when you uh guys for training
got the laser tag system whatever
it's called um when you shot it was it
what did the gun fight was it like it
was a blanket oh so usually so it
sounded real well blanks don't sound as
real as real guns but yes it went bang
yeah yeah yeah and
then it shot the laser at the same time
what's the difference between the sound
i don't think i've ever heard of blank
there's a choir it's it's it's
considerably quieter although the
machine gun blanks are pretty freaking
loud
but like a an m4 or m16 type blank is
pretty weak bro
like pry i don't need air pro
oh for i mean it's loud but it's not
it's not crazy yeah yeah you ever watch
a snatch
movie
yeah i don't remember too much about it
okay richie anyway they they had these
uh
replica they were gonna do some robbery
oh yeah this is the this is the 50 cal
that says replica on it right the desert
eagle 50 cal that says no no no no isn't
that in that movie though yes but then
close that's not what what happened was
actually yes so it was like the that
scene
or the part of that scene anyway so they
these guys these three thugs go and they
get these guns that are replica guns
he's like i even got extra loud blanks
so that actually now kind of makes a
little bit more sense it's like okay
there's extra loud blanks well yeah if
the if regular blanks are more quiet
yeah then that makes sense
but then even though they were making
jokes they're like why in case we got a
definite to death or whatever yeah he
said or whatever no so the desert eagle
wasn't the replica the desert eagle was
real
they had the replicas so they came in
they did i don't know they did whatever
they did then they came one of them say
replica on it though all their guns all
the thugs guns so they were pointing it
at vinnie blue or
his real name uh bullet tooth tony
uh-huh
who's this big played by vinnie i forget
his last name um
and he's just cruising they're having a
beer and they're like you know they try
to intimidate him or whatever and then
vinnie goes into this or bullet tooth
goes into this kind of cool speech and
then at the end of speech it says and
the fact that you have replica written
down the side of your guns and it kind
of zooms you know guy richie has this
good cinematic style
shows the replica of words
and then it goes and the fact that i
have desert eagle and he pulls it out
written on mine
and then he goes back into his speech or
whatever it was just a super good scene
but the desert eagle was real they had
replicas okay
uh
we you know this guy's talking about
barbed wire shell holes trenches
artillery and placements like all the
stuff to make it real we had hollywood
set designers come down and square away
our training sites and it was freaking
awesome it was awesome
and then i
like we do what the moojs would do which
is like set tires on fire in the middle
of the streets and you come down there
your night vision's getting all messed
up from that there's graffiti on the
walls there's
speakers that are playing the call to
prayer it would be
it would be realistic man yeah and
that's so good too because when you
first started saying that i was like oh
wait you got hollywood i mean that's
kind of going is it that deep bro like
did you and then but then i thought
about it so when i first started playing
football i was 11 years old pop warner
football and
you know in a regular football practice
especially back then might be different
now but back then is you know you warm
up you do some exercises push-ups and
stuff you do like these kind of they're
called grass drills but they're like
essentially coordination drills
and then you do some technique stuff and
then you do a scrimmage pretty much
every day with your pads on too so it's
so it's essentially
it's essentially full contact scrimmages
right
so
but the scrimmage would have and this is
pretty this is pretty standard where you
have like kind of the starting team in
the secondary team and then you have
everyone else who's not on the first or
second string plays the defense right
but they they show the defense that the
team that we're gonna play that week
what defense they play
so and then if the player and here's
what our coaches would do if there was a
star player somewhere like maybe the
defensive end or something like that was
a star player or the safety or the
linebacker was kind of the star player
especially when you're young it kind of
it stands out more
um they would get like one of our really
good players to play that guy
and if he did something unique that
would make that guy do that unique thing
so they tried to try to make it
realistic like and replicate it right so
i remember them i remember thinking like
all right i mean you know we run plays
but i didn't realize how much of a
difference it is from running plays
against a generic defense versus running
plays against a very specific defense
so and you know i'm 11 years old so
it's not dawning on me right so i'm like
whatever though we'll practice or
whatever and from week to week
you'd be different you could feel the
difference with who we're playing and
they'd all be the same guys guys on our
team right in practice but rewind back
to that first game and the first time
you play and you see the exact same
thing
as we were practicing it's different
jerseys which is weird but even that
little detail it's kind of like whoa
that kind of stood out you could see the
little differences like oh i've been
used to this practice so much you know
over these weeks or whatever the
littlest difference stands out so the
more accurate you can make it the better
so you don't get distracted by all these
little differences right
so then i thought back to your
you know scenario where you're hiring
set designers and you're like talking
about burning tires and doing all this
little stuff that i'm like who cares if
there's a burning tire or not you know
like right you're here to do a mission
the burning tire is not going to
distract you the thing is
it wouldn't be surprising to me given
what i already know everything would be
distraction if you haven't seen it
before the burning tire is so kind of
like that's kind of a big distraction
actually when you think about it or it
could be yeah yeah how's it affecting
your night vision what are you gonna do
yeah it's a little thing but it makes a
big difference that's so true so true
even like okay so like football there i
remember so this guy's name is kelly
he's kind of you know kids are bigger
so they'd replicate him in practice they
put my brother or something somebody
there right um someone who's just like a
like a big a good athlete for practice
but this guy kelly he wasn't just a good
athlete he was kind of a mean person so
it was like you could tell the
difference between
an athlete and being a mean person
the difference between that you know and
it was like a thing i was like man they
should have told my brother whoever else
was prac just to be mean or something
like that that would have helped just
that little detail would have helped
they were a little surprised yeah
yeah well i always tell people like i'm
doing my first jiu jitsu tournament what
should i be ready for and i'm like oh
yeah be ready for your opponent to go
crazier than anything you've seen in
your jiu jitsu academy yeah because
that's what's going to happen yeah might
not be the first match might be the same
but like it's almost guaranteed it
probably is going to be your first match
person's going to get nuts
yes
yeah and actually there's ways to get
ready for that even though it does get a
little bit more just like the football
extraordinary thing
it gets dangerous after a while if you
start practicing that hard with it you
know yeah you can't but to do like an
in-house tournament or like or or a
replicated tournament like they that we
did it a few times where it's like oh
everyone like make a big circle are you
gonna do a thing points matter yeah yeah
exactly yeah
start start tracking points that's the
thing right and people watching and
yelling and cheering and they're being a
ref counting your points it's kind of
like when things matter a little bit
more it's like right even it's all just
psychological but it helps isn't
everything
[Music]
the handbook on squad combat says one
should use real troops as much as
possible to represent the enemy the
soldiers will much less
will be much less likely to make
mistakes in wartime if they see during
the training instead of a dummy a real
and active enemy this is you know you
talked about using that laser tag system
and when we started using ammunition
and paintball was just totally different
i mean imagine that
that paper target doesn't shoot back it
doesn't move that's the main concerns of
the enemy they're going to shoot back if
they're going to move
a paper target doesn't shoot back and
doesn't move
so
that training is even though live fire
training
you have to do it and you need to do it
to a point where it's second nature live
fire against targets
but
the real stressors should come when you
start doing force on force training yeah
yeah that that's a
just
the person or the enemy whatever
shooting back just that not the moving
thing like what if there was stationary
targets that actually shot back just
that alone huge deal yeah on the flip
side just them moving around versus not
moving huge deal totally and then now
you go now you're missing in live fire
training uh and this is obviously my
little theory i don't sit in the
scenario but
those two put together yeah but isn't
that kind of night and day it's a whole
different training training scenario and
we adjusted our tactics when we figured
that out
because our our tactics had evolved from
vietnam
they had evolved to a point where they
weren't realistic anymore
because we spent all these we spent 20
years
shooting at paper targets that weren't
moving and so we developed tactics to do
it very quickly
but it was against inanimate objects the
minute we started getting
paintball and simunition into the game
you start realizing oh that's not going
to work we can't all stand in a big
group like this
we need to take this into consideration
we need to take that into consideration
all so things we got a lot better we
started doing force on force training
it's the same thing to be said for
jiu-jitsu and ufc
right when you just when i used to walk
up to you and throw like a whatever
punch and you would fall down like i
threw a simulated punch and you
simulated falling down and i simulated
broke your you know
your heart with a with a two-finger
punch or whatever you know what i mean
it's called the dimma yeah with the
dimock then it's like it seemed to work
good
like it was pretty awesome yep but then
the minute i got into a fight with some
drunk wrestler
i got caught a beat down i'm like this
doesn't work
and what jiu-jitsu is jiu-jitsu is like
oh you're training to
you're training as hard as you can to
put the person into submission hold that
then they don't die
because they tap well it's the same
thing i shoot you with paintball in the
neck
or the thighs which is where i'm aiming
because they aren't the worst
so
when i shoot you there you don't die but
you learn a lesson
so how different is it you ever played
regular paintball yes just regular okay
so munition that's the people that you
guys have what's the difference is there
any difference what's information
simulation you shoot from your real
weapon yeah and it goes bang it goes it
goes bang out loud you know it's not
it's just a little it's a little tiny
bang uh you have to change your
magazines it's not like where you have
400 paintballs and a freaking hopper on
top of your gun you're just laying waste
right
you have to change magazines the kind of
simulation does jam a little bit oh
which is a bummer what's the um what
would you call it the propellant or
whatever like how does it it's an
explosion yeah it's like a little
explosion
and so and it comes out i would i don't
know if it comes out like faster it
seems to i think it's a little bit
faster and i think it hits a little bit
harder than it's a smaller projectile so
it hurts a little bit more oh okay but
but it is it has paint in it and you get
you know you get a little paint on you
and
it's very effective it's the thing the
reason that we also use the laser tag
system is because the paintball and this
ammunition is only good for you know
30 40
yards
so it's good in the house it's good in
the hallway it's good in a cqc
environment
but out in the field is no good it
doesn't work good you can use a little
bit like even in a mountain environment
you need to use regular paintball guns
eventually so that you can get some
distance you can put down cover fire
like across the street
but even that's not very that's not very
accurate
um but then but then the lasers they're
good at like three four or five hundred
yards well maybe 300 yards but but
that's that's legit but you can get some
legit training and do the laser and this
is just my
predicting or estimating kind of
imagining so when you're with the lasers
don't you lose an element of stress a
little bit because there's nothing
actually coming in hitting you yep and
what what was funny was
so we used those in the desert
and if you got shot you're gonna get put
down and if you got put down someone's
gonna have to carry you out
if you're getting carried out you're
gonna get dropped you're going to get
like it sucks for everyone
and so when
it would actually
when you would watch guys going through
like a
urban scenario getting shot with
paintball they would just charge through
it like they didn't care like the
instructors if they're gonna put you
down they put you down
but when
on the laser tag system it had a
near-miss little you had a speaker on
your shoulder so when you would get shot
at it would go you know
make a little noise and you knew that
you were getting shot at oh that's cool
and when you would watch guys as those
near-misses started coming they would
dive for cover
like they were getting shot at for real
i'm not kidding they were dying like
they were getting shot up for widow
because they if they got shot
everything was gonna go to they
were gonna get bogged down other people
are gonna shot they were gonna have to
get carried out
which is a total gut check
and
and it would happen a lot but you'd see
those guys
it was very effective training yeah but
sometimes you know when you're just
doing a laser tag with no punishment
whatsoever yeah you can definitely get a
little bit cocky
with paintball you don't really get too
cocky because it hurts and you don't
want to get you know you'll you'll move
from cover to cover yeah because you
don't want to get lit up yeah
yeah it's funny there's all these little
details that you don't really think
about that play such a big role in the
whole scenario oh yeah the guy's diving
for cover in
using the laser system was that's when
you knew like oh this is really
effective yeah yeah
so and then you could also put down
suppressive fire
because if you were you know over in a
building i could just shoot at the
building and as soon as you started
maneuvering out so you could shoot back
you'd like get near misses and you'd
hide oh yeah so that means i could you
know i could put down cover fire while
my buddy moved yeah and it was totally
effective
that speaker kind of makes a big
difference i didn't really think about
it where especially if you have that
association like oh if i could put down
this major consequence sucks because
without the speak because i'm not
thinking speaker does all that which
obviously it's more advanced than i
thought so the if you're just like oh
you only get the indicator that you got
shot right which is kind of like the
regular laser tag yeah that i played
when i was young you don't they don't
know near misses nothing like that so
you think oh yeah copper firing won't
work that good because
yeah part what basically the whole
concept of cover fire is you're being
scared of those bullets
even though they don't hit you but then
yeah if you got that speaker buzzing
oh but then
but laser doesn't like
hit the building doesn't because a
bullet hitting the building is like kind
of a big thing right that'll get your
head down yeah 100
so cover fire in a way potentially
is way more effective in real fire
for all because it's everything yes
yes and that was one thing that was
even with even with the laser tag you'd
still see guys do like stuff where
you're like hey would you have really
done that
because you got shot 19 times or
whatever you know
it was a little hard to simulate the
fear of death yeah but i'll tell you
what getting getting buddy carried or
having to buddy carry someone out for
six kilometers in the desert
on night vision it sucked and guys hated
it and so they would do everything they
could to stay alive and accomplish the
mission yeah that feels like a solid
little like
proxy yeah you know for oh it was a
solid little proxy
i mean obviously you can't shoot the
guys and kill them right but man it's
you don't want to hump someone out in
the desert it's freaking terrible
especially someone like you yeah and in
and sometimes guys would you know a task
unit would have
down men
it would just be awful
like if they did if they didn't if the
leadership wasn't making good decisions
and they weren't covered and moving if
things weren't you know simple and clear
and then you prioritize you would get 12
13 14 and sometimes you know we'd kill
so many of them and be like all right
you guys are done just walk back you you
failed oh yeah that's when you're
getting reloaded and now you got a whole
nother stress right because they don't
want to get they don't want to fail
of course yeah so be a bummer but it was
really good it was it was great to be
able to
be a part of that training yeah that's
that's cool how it evolved into like
that that close to realistic
yeah those paintballs like especially if
the simulation hurt more that like
paintball kind of hurts
like finishing hurts too yeah but i'd
say it's probably about the same yeah
probably about the same bro i got
whacked like couple times like in the
side yeah and i wasn't wearing like
padding or nothing just the face one
yeah um and yeah and leaves like a
straight up wound like on your thing
like a welding or whatever
yeah that's something it's not nothing
i'll tell you that
[Applause]
thoroughness
realism in german training methods is
one aspect of their general demand for
thoroughness german officers in
particular and the enlisted men as well
are taught to regard themselves as men
engaged in a highly skilled and highly
honorable profession and to take pride
in acquiring the details of military
techniques to encourage this point of
view soldiers are put as little
as possible on fatigue work and
non-military labors which are performed
by civilians
and the last thing we'll talk about from
this document
is marksmanship during german training
has tended to put emphasis on volume of
fire rather than accuracy an observer
believes that their ability to
concentrate fire at vital point is
superior to our own but that their
standards of marksmanship are inferior
however a german article in late 1941
makes the point that volume of
mechanical fire will not replace
accurate individual shooting and that
sharpshooters can perform invaluable
tactical missions
so they
they did concentrate on volume of fire
and they concentrate on marksmanship the
basic skills of shooting
and there you have it and and as you can
see um
many of those principles
are are the same principles that are
taught in the us military and really the
same principles that are taught by any
sort of leadership
education
right and
and that's why it's very strange to read
this document
and recognize that these principles are
being utilized by
the most evil or at least one of the top
evil
empires
to have ever existed
and yet they're talking about taking
care of their people and and making sure
everyone understands the why
and you can see as i mentioned earlier
that that while these principles were
implemented down the chain of command
clearly
at the top
these principles didn't exist at all the
tyrannical leader of hitler massive ego
driven by his own insecurities
driven by paranoia
lack of trust like all these things that
these book this book talks about
hitler to them
and
that's why you end up in this disaster
and this horrific the the horrific
atrocities that that the nazis created
and the horrific atrocities of the war
which which you know you you know you
were talking about
earlier i kind of made fun of you about
like oh the world didn't exist before i
was here right
it's it's kind of inconceivable
in some ways to understand
the broad absolute horror of world war
ii and the holocaust and
the the deaths
the the woundings
the loss of life
the destroyed
uh communities
it's it's it's kind of hard
to really truly understand that those
things occurred
at all it can be very very difficult to
understand that
they seem inconceivable i guess
if you truly look at him at season it
seems inconceivable if you think about
the millions of peop you know millions
of people
millions of people dying
it's hard to it's hard to understand a
million dollars it's hard to understand
you know a million a million people
going to a a you know at a at a big
giant arena there's only 100 000 people
there picture that times ten
then that's there you have a million
and each one of those people is an
individual with a family and dreams and
a life and and and thoughts
and when you start talking about the
scale of death and destruction in world
war ii it's just
it's hard to conceive what that really
means
but
it did happen and
[Music]
we
have to study history
and have to study our enemies and what
their thought processes were to make
sure
that
history does not repeat
itself
with that we appreciate you all listen
to the podcast
if you want to support the podcast and
support yourself at the same time
might as well support some good causes
out there right
let's support some good it's true let's
make the world a better place let's
start with ourselves yes make yourself
better yeah
physically better
mentally better
spiritually better
let's do all those things yep
it's true
take care of yourself on every front
that's what we need to do
and then you can take care of other
people then you can help other people so
if you want to help yourself from a
fuel
and i'm not talking about gasoline for
your car or maybe diesel for your truck
i'm talking about for you you need fuel
yeah similar concept similar concept you
want to get good fuel you kind of want
to get the best fuel yes sir you might
want to get for yourself some jackal
fuel
it's true
yeah it's very true uh you know as i
keep reminding you off air
that i am on the path kind of strict oh
yeah yeah like kind of legitimately
strict
ever since um
covid
started
i put on some pounds some good some bad
and uh you know varying levels of
success in going back to you know to
where i was before that also i just got
back from the motherland all right yeah
and you know how that can go sometimes
but nonetheless the point is i'm on the
path
so
routine back in full swing hundred
percent
right
was like three years ago yes sir yeah
yeah it was uh
you know like i said
let's make a recommendation don't go off
the path for three years everybody i
would say this so how's that is it two
years
it's coming up on three years maybe
two years two years right and a half i
don't know something like that i was
like i'm off the path because of kovitz
well you know two and a half years ago
well jiu-jitsu stops
for a long time
the routine jiu-jitsu okay we got little
pockets here and there you get in this
is true but the routine stops
you know i still can work out at the
house or whatever but cardio goes way
down sometimes like off the grid let's
face it
so i'm just lifting some of them
yourself on full report
maybe someone else out there can relate
to the realities of situations like this
nonetheless boom yeah sure i got back on
the path but i never really got back to
where it was
and after a while you know we just got
tired of that one you know so we just
went more strict that's what i'm saying
but there are certain elements in there
that have always been on the path
especially with the fuel with the jackal
fuel part of it
part of the point as well so well thank
god you had jocko fuel because
apparently you need
you were just you were just wandering
around never mind off the path you're
off the reservation
i know and the way i'm putting is more
like i just freaking just let myself go
i didn't let myself go but i put on like
a good
10 15 pounds
which isn't yeah i know it's not like
night and day kind of a scenario but
and that's probably why i didn't get
back right away because it wasn't like
that big of a thing but it was still a
nagging thing i feel like jack you see
i'm saying you drinking milk i'm
drinking monkeys
and actually i just got on this um
protocol which i always knew about but
you know sometimes it takes a little bit
for to implement where if you if with
your diet if you just control for like
the protein getting enough protein
whatever your workout program kind of
requires or whatever
and then you fill in the rest of the
macros accordingly it depends on where
you want to go what your goal is or
whatever that's like a really good way
to stay on it so i'm saying like if
because if you don't control for protein
and you don't get enough protein you
don't build your muscle the way you want
to do it you risk over training you do
all this stuff whatever nonetheless it's
better it's a good way to do it yeah so
you've got to get that protein yeah 100
how much are you getting
uh
one gram per no like 0.6 0.6 grams per
yeah
right that's like you need to up it man
yeah you up those numbers from what i
understand i mean i wonder you're losing
weight you're starving to death over
there right you're losing muscle mass
no it depends on where what you read and
where you read it um it's gonna go
anywhere from like point five all the
way up to like one
per pound per or per pound or per
kilogram
no per pound
for real yeah okay it depends
so um i don't know hey look that's
that's your journey
to look into that kind of stuff and
figure out what's right for you bro
okay so let's say i weigh
and i'm taking you want me to freaking
eat 220 grams of protein in a day that
that's what you're saying i don't know
that's ten monks
i love milk i like milk a lot but bro i
could you know ten ten yeah even if you
break it up three milkshakes
per meal
i don't know i don't know okay we don't
recommend that i'm not saying yes i'm
not saying no i'm just like but not
that's so much currently i'm not at ten
no i'm at one sometimes two actually but
mine are doubles yes i don't mind yeah i
only have doubles okay yeah there you go
boom nonetheless
we're on the program
check um also good news with the energy
drinks if you didn't know already yeah
real good news all the old good news is
still there healthy for your energy
drink
no sugar
sugar is more evil than you think by the
way yeah 100
i think it's evil so you're not catching
me on that one it's not as evil as i can
if you were to you know how like i'm
sure there's some
point in your life where you like looked
into sugar a little bit deeper than
maybe you do daily and then realize oh
shoot this is kind of there's some
issues with sugar sugar is real like
yeah evil you could start looking back
into it and probably find some more
stuff yep that's how so you're saying it
is even more evil than even i thought
and i thought it was pretty damn evil
that is my contention yes and
good news like i said old good news but
good news no sugar in this one so it's
all healthy stuff
so boom that's still the case but the
additional good news we got a
reformulated tastes in there for all of
them oh yeah all of them all the all the
discipline go tastes good as a hell now
like it will
we're gonna win on taste yeah we're
going to win on taste tastes better than
the other
let's go what do we call them energy
drinks
taste better than the other ones
straight up better yeah try that still
no sugar yeah still no still no
chemicals in there
just good for you
and now it tastes good too
it's true the other flavors you might
have had one or two flavors that you
liked but the other ones you kind of now
you'll like them all yeah you'll and
you'll love one or two of them that's
the difference that's what we just did
yeah there was a few before that you
hated you won't even hate any of them
yeah
now you're gonna you're gonna like them
all you're gonna love two or three of
them
and you're gonna be good to go you're
gonna find your little thing yeah man
it's true it's all true
fuel.com yep uh don't freak don't forget
a lot of but we don't we haven't
actually talked about it whatever the
joint stuff that's a big deal because
you can be on any program but yeah if
your joints your knees start giving out
shoulders all this kind of stuff right
you're kind of off the program a little
bit
voluntarily off the program so yeah keep
that in mind you want overall health
you want to be able to keep going
yeah
endurance
endure durable be durable that helps big
time
um yeah some vitamins in the vitamin d
cold or immunity by just checking
chocolatefuel.com.com
go to wawa get some drinks we gotta we
got a ready to drink coming monk coming
have you seen that have you tasted it
yet nope hella good yeah perfect
perfect do they add like um you know how
for example
i'll put like half a banana in there or
something like that do they add anything
else in there no it's just straight up
formulated
perfect ratios you could throw banana in
there scientifically proven perfect
ratios okay all right that's good uh go
to wawa get the drinks go to vitamin
shop get this stuff go to if you're in
texas go to heb go to heb rolling hot
and get yourself some milk that's what
i'm saying uh also get some
origin hunt
originusa.com you get a bunch of you can
get jeans boots you know what you can
get but you can get stuff that's made in
america
not stuff that's literally made
in a tyrannical country like the one we
just talked about
it's a little bit different but the
principles are kind of there
let's not support that let's support
america where people are free
how about that that's a good idea
originusa.com get yourself some boots
jeans some jiu-jitsu gear ghee oh yeah
it's true also you want to represent why
you're on this path like
i think a lot of us do
pretty much every day
chocolatestore.com shirts hats hoodies
on there as well i know it's summertime
i get it but at some point it's going to
be fall then winter i've got some honeys
on there
um
discipline equals freedom that's what
you're representing the jackal store
stuff uh the short locker by the way
what
i don't know that i've that you've ever
told me your assessment of the shirt
locker in any thorough way let's see i i
like it
there's my assessment
you don't know what that is subscription
situation get a new shirt every month
creative they're different different
designs
pretty much every single one has been a
success varying levels of you know there
are sporadic
um outliers that might you know they
might be too hard there's a couple of
objections over objections they
the the conceptual element behind them
might have went over some people's heads
or maybe hit them too hard or not too
hard right in the face yeah a little bit
that's what it seems like sherlocker.com
is that a thing no no it's just
jackostore.com i'm just making up my own
cops
jockostore.com you is a big thing
click shirt locker boom check it out you
can see some previews too that's the
thing look i'm not going to give it all
away
you know as far as what designs or what
or whatever but you can see some
previews some hints of like what the
next one is what some past ones were
also if you're a member you can buy any
of the past ones by the way that's
pretty legit yeah so you know you you
thought you missed out on one then where
you can go back but you can bring it
right back you want your neighbor
because this is how this happens a lot
where you're going to be wearing one and
someone would be like bro where'd you
get that shirt like the one that says
good right you know we have some good
shirts on the store cool now we got a
better one there's or a different one
slightly and it's like it's cool it
looks really good and i got a literal
phone call saying where who got that
shirt where can we get that shirt my
wife wants it
you sign up you can get your wife on
your neighbor one whatever you like same
thing check
uh that's jocklestore.com
subscribe to the podcast check out the
jaco underground we just recorded a
couple episodes of that talking
interesting information talk about
keeping our own little platform we have
our own little platform we don't own
this platform that you're listening to
unless you're in jock on the ground
right now but we don't own uh itunes
we don't own
spotify
we don't own youtube we get kicked off
any of those i don't know
we talked about the nazis today will
that get us kicked off oh yeah
i mean
who knows yeah there's like terms that
get you like flagged kind of flagged
yeah
yeah they're for real are yeah in fact
it's so weird been flagged before
oh yeah we've been flagged a few times
and that's kind of what prompted this
jocko underground.com because we don't
know when we're going to get kicked off
for saying something
yeah
so
if you want to support that eight
dollars and eighteen cents a month we
appreciate it check out the youtube
channel check out psychological warfare
check out flipsidecampus.com dakota
meyer making awesome stuff to hang on
your wall
i've written a bunch of books
check them out
you know what they are echelon front
talked about that a little bit today
leadership lab ftx we got the muster
coming up
so
i think that's the next one is in
atlanta hotlanta october 12th to the
14th we sold out all these things
so
if you want to come get there early
register go to streamownership.com
for r or that's echelonfront.com if you
want to do online training you'll go
through some courses you want to
understand this stuff at a deeper level
go to extremeownership.com
and take some courses some online
courses
i'll be sitting there telling you what's
up
you can come and ask me
questions extremeownership.com
and if you want to do your duty from a
charity perspective check out mark lee's
mom mama lee she's got a great charity
organization and if you want to donate
to her
organization or you want to get involved
go to
americasmightywarriors.org and you've
also got heroes and horses.org micah
he's up there in the wilderness
they're wrapping up their course right
now 41 days out in the bush reconnecting
with your soul
that's for veterans check it out heroes
and horses.org and if you wanna
well if you wanna see us on twitter or
the gram or
the facebook echoing on there but look
just be careful
fair warning the algorithms there the
brainwashing out we said people getting
brainwashed
by the nazis
you're getting brainwashed too when
you're staring at that little screen
don't let it happen watch out for the
algorithm
and finally salute to the greatest
generation
the world war ii veterans that fought
against the nazi
power the tyranny the oppression
the greatest generation that saved
freedom in our world so a salute to them
and also thanks to the soldiers sailors
airmen and marines that are out there
right now as we speak holding the line
thank you to all of you and the same
goes to our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all the first
responders that keep us safe every day
thank you for holding the line here at
home
and everyone else out there remember
this idea
remember to begin your day with a
mission
begin the day with a mission
and if you approach
every day
and you approach every task as if it was
a battle
eventually
you could approach battles
like they're a task
that's what we've got for today
every day is a battle
go get in the fight
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out